Sound good?
Yeah.
We're good.
Five,
four,
three,
two.
That was a.
That was like,
you didn't do the film.
I wasn't sure it was her finger button.
Chris,
what's up man?
How are you?
Good man.
How you doing,
Joe?
Thanks for doing this.
Uh,
for people to name right now,
Chris is the author of how to hike the
Appalachian trail and he's also,
I've talked about this on the podcast
for this is his company is not a
sponsor.
This is company,
a green belly meals and these are these
really delicious bars that are.
They weigh like 50 pounds a brick filled
with nutrients and food and they're
really good for people who did this
crazy appalachian trail thing and these,
these bars that you sell have become
very popular with hunters and people
that like to go on a backpack.
Journeys deep into the back country and
I found out about you from a rich,
rich,
rich outdoors podcast and that's where I
listened to you on his podcast and
that's why.
That's why you're here.
That's what I got.
Cody loved the podcast.
Yeah,
it's a good podcast.
So what the fuck for people who don't
know the Appalachian trail,
we've talked about this on the podcast
before,
but it's a trail where people walk from
Georgia,
right all the way up to Maine or,
or vice versa,
vice versa if you want,
if you're a madman and it takes you.
How many months?
Five to seven.
Took me a little over six.
So you just hike for six months,
but when you're at month three,
do you ever go like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Long story short?
Yeah.
Uh,
and by month three I was actually
approaching winter time and you know,
wintertime camping is just a
fundamentally different experience.
So not only have you been hiking that
long and you're tired and your body's
just,
you know,
just done doing it every day of hiking.
But then the elements of the,
of the winter come in and that's,
that was a different ballgame entirely.
You know,
how many people have done this?
Less than $10,000.
That's a lot of fucking people.
Yeah,
it is still a lot.
I would have said like 50,
uh,
there's another thing called the triple
crown,
which is the,
it's the,
uh,
it's,
it's the 80 a pacific crest trail and
the continental divide trail and I think
less than a hundred people have done all
three of those.
The Pacific crest trail,
is that the one that goes from like
Mexico tall to
Canada?
It's through California.
That's insane.
How long did that one take?
Uh,
I think so.
Appalachian trail is 2100 miles and the
Pacific crest trail,
I believe it's like 25,
26 when he was 700 miles.
But the trail gradient is a lot easier.
So I think like on any given day you can
actually hike more miles even though the
trails is longer than the 80,
but I think people actually finish it
faster than the eat.
I like how you call it the 80 inside
lingo
maniacs.
Are you hiking maniacs?
Yeah.
What the fuck got you into this man?
Uh,
it's a long story.
Short boy scouts.
Yeah,
I did.
Um,
I joined boy scouts later than most
people I joined when I was 14.
And uh,
you know,
the kind of the pinnacle of the Boy
Scout Careers,
getting your Eagle Scout.
And I joined with that in mind.
I was like,
okay,
I'm joining later than most I joined
when most people are quitting boy
scouts,
you know,
they go from cub scouts like 13 and I
quit by joined and I was like,
all right,
I want my eagle scout and we,
you have to,
in order to get your Eagle Scout spin 20
nights in the woods,
not consecutively,
but you have to,
um,
get your camping merit badge and get
your camping merit badge.
You have to spend the night 20 nights in
the woods.
So,
uh,
you know,
that was in Georgia and the foothills of
the Appalachian mountains are in north
Georgia.
So the,
you know,
the,
the beginning of the Appalachian trail
is also,
you know,
right there.
So we went on several trips up there in
north Georgia and I got exposed to it,
you know,
and I think the,
just the idea of getting on this small
trail and um,
you know,
kind of looking down and understanding
that this thing goes on for 2000 more
miles was just kinda like one that just
seems crazy.
Right.
You know,
there's no way I'm ever going to have
enough time or we're kind of the uh,
the drive to do that.
But um,
yeah,
there was definitely kind of the
mystery.
I was like,
Oh man,
that just seems like an adventure I want
to do.
Uh,
so yeah,
that was,
that was definitely the beginning of it
when I was about 14 years old going up
there and hiking on it for overnight
trips.
Now,
how does one fund something like this?
Because I would assume you,
they have to be independently wealthy or
you have to have squirreled away enough
money so you could walk for seven months
and feed yourself in the process.
Or did you work along the way?
I mean,
you can't.
What do you do?
I think there's a big misconception that
like a,
it takes a lot of money,
but in reality it's like what are your
expenses?
It's just food,
you know,
and then gear ahead of time.
So,
um,
you know,
most hikers are kind of known as the,
like the Athletic Hobo,
you know,
like they are grimy,
they're not spending money on hotels,
there's no accommodation,
there's no car payments,
you know,
they're walking so you can really
eliminate all expenses when you do that.
But,
um,
I mean for me,
I had a,
I was an accountant,
so,
uh,
I'd been an accountant for about,
two years and I saved up some money and
uh,
I basically knew that I wanted to take
the hit so I started saving up some
money,
but any,
any given through hiker,
that's what they're called.
Anybody that does,
um,
you know,
it starts in Georgia,
ends in Maine or Maine to Georgia.
Anybody that does that hike,
um,
in one consecutive runs,
it's called a through hiker,
but any,
any through hike I would,
I would say it takes about $5,000 from
gear to sleeping in hotels about once a
week to resupplying foods.
So thinking about $5,000 for six months
of living like ain't too bad,
you know,
you think about $5,000 for six months of
living in the real world.
Like I've never lived that cheaply,
you know?
Right.
Well,
it's not that bad.
No,
but like you're saying hotels once a
week.
So what would merit a hotel stay is a
ferocious whether,
like what,
um,
a lot of things.
So you,
you typically are within five to seven
days of a town,
so the trail kind of goes along the
mountains and then about every five to
seven days you come to a trail crossing,
which is a highway or anything that
would lead to a nearby town and every
five to seven days you're out of food.
You know,
that's the biggest thing that I think
pulls you into towns.
You need to resupply.
So you're not out there foraging for
nuts and berries or or hunting or
anything like that.
You're,
you're relying on getting to town,
getting to a grocery store and getting
all your food.
So every five to seven days you go into
town and you get food.
It's like,
whoa man,
I also haven't showered in five to seven
days.
I also haven't done laundry in five to
seven days and you know,
you're hiking with really one change of
clothes.
So you can imagine if you're hiking 20
miles a day,
the grime and the dirt that can build
up.
So when you come to town,
you want to do laundry,
resupply food,
you want to stay in a hotel,
you want to clean off your body,
your feet are starting to grow stuff.
You know,
you've been sweating,
walking through muddy trails.
There's just a lot of grime.
When you get to town,
it's like a big refresh,
you know?
But when you make that big refresh,
do you,
do you ever go,
why am I doing this?
Yeah,
it's kind of,
it's kind of ironic.
You're on you.
You make the intention of going down the
trail to get outside of town and outside
of society,
but one of the biggest things you look
forward to is getting back into town,
you know?
Um,
yeah.
And it's kind of like you said,
well,
you know,
when you get to town it's like,
why am I doing this?
You are kind of.
I was kind of dreading getting back out
on the trail a lot of times because it
was just so.
Oh Man,
I have a hot shower,
like I shaved,
like,
so nice.
Yeah.
The first time I did any camping in
since the boys scouts.
You're.
Yeah,
I was a boy scout when I was 13 for one
summer,
but these fucking inner city creeps that
I went to the boy scouts with and
Jamaica Plain Massachusetts,
which is like,
and now it's more a gentrified,
but back then it was kind of a shady
neighborhood picking on,
you know.
Well,
they were,
they would Thai kids up and leave them
in the woods.
They would tie you up to your bunk and
then leave you in the woods.
They put toothpaste all over your
clothes,
but you can't get out there just fucking
shitty kids.
It was,
it was like a total free fall for all.
It was just really didn't because we
went to the woods in New Hampshire.
That's where the boy scouts or take you
up and I remember like these fucking
camp counselors are weird guys that
barely paying attention and it's
basically like all these inner city
teenagers,
street scouts,
yeah.
There's just running rampant.
Like uh,
there was a rifle range where they would
shoot 20 twos and there was an archery
range.
And I remember I was at the archery
I hurt and I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And they go,
that's a ricochet and I'm at what?
Alright,
check please.
And so I decided to just go fishing
every day I was there.
I would avoid everybody.
There was like all those things on the
agenda that you were supposed to do,
fuck you.
I just took off and I went and found
this pond and I would go to that pond
every day for the week that I was up
there.
My point being sent from that time from
13 till 2012,
I had had not gone camping and then I
went camping in Montana in October and
really cold,
it was like nine degrees and we were out
there for six or seven days and when we
went back we went back to a hotel and I
remember thinking this is the greatest
shower the world has ever known.
Like that feeling.
You don't appreciate showers.
Oh No.
Probably nobody appreciates a shower,
like an appalachian trail hiker.
Right.
Does that make sense?
It's pure ecstasy,
like showers normal,
like a normal showers normal.
But it's like if you got to shower after
you're hiking for seven days with muddy
feet and your clothes stink and
everything's gross and
yeah,
you need that deprivation to appreciate
it,
you know,
you do.
Right.
Because most people don't appreciate
showers.
Yeah.
I guess it's like the starving kid
needing,
you know,
when he gets food,
he's like,
oh,
you know,
yeah.
Or like a guy who just getting out of
prison and get some sex.
You're not getting any prison.
Um,
so what kind of Weirdos do you meet on
the trail?
You gotta yeah,
you gotTa keep in mind anybody who's
willing to take six months out of their
life to go to the woods,
it's going to be a different breed.
I mean,
I think you definitely have your
stereotypes.
Um,
some people are other just kind of for
the challenge and the a out of,
dare I say athletic side of it,
but it's like a different side of it,
right?
Sure.
It's Kinda like a,
I want to power through this and see how
much my body can handle.
You get those kinds of hikers,
but you definitely get the,
the hippie dropout,
a life kind of guys,
you know,
it's just like I just want to get out
there and,
and,
uh,
get away from society for a little bit
so that,
that kind of stereotype.
You definitely,
those are just gonna get some Weirdos
out there.
Yeah,
I would imagine if you ever had an
uncomfortable moments where you like
scared to camp with people.
No doubt.
There was one time a man,
there was a Pennsylvania.
So Pennsylvania,
uh,
you know,
a lot of those x coal towns,
um,
their economy just plummeted and the,
it goes through a lot of those towns.
So you'd have some people near town
going out there for an overnight or,
and they are what are called,
they're like these three walled wooden
structures that are made by,
um,
well all sorts of organizations make
them.
But in general they're about every 10 to
20 miles along the 80.
So in theory you can sleep in these
every night and not need a tent.
I wouldn't recommend that.
But,
um,
you do try to sleep in the shelters as
much as possible.
But the fact that there are these
shelters,
a lot of people kind of bottleneck to
them because they know they're there.
So you will sometimes get to a shelter
at night and it won't only be a t
through hikers there,
there'll be people from town.
Um,
but they,
I remember one time in Pennsylvania,
there were these,
there was this couple.
Yeah,
they were literally,
it was pouring rain.
So we get there.
And I was like,
there's no way I'm camping out.
There's no way I'm hiking on like I'm
sleeping in the shelter,
you know,
I was drenched to the bone,
my gear was drenched and I was pissed
off.
It was like a midnight,
you know,
I had been hiking all day.
I was just exhausted.
I'm so,
so excited to get to the shelter and
there's a couple and they are literally
yelling at each other,
you know,
I,
I can hear them for like a model,
like just furiously yelling at each
other and you get there and they are.
Um,
I never really knew,
but I'm assuming they were cracked out.
I saw some little glass pieces going in
between their hands and just the way
they're acting.
He kept like throwing up his fists at or
he smashed a bottle on the wall in the
shelter and uh,
yeah,
he pulled out a knife at one point and
it was just like.
So are these individuals shelters or is
a large shelter when you see three
walls?
Like how big are these things?
Uh,
I think they're usually maybe
about this size,
length of this table,
maybe about 10,
10 feet wide.
And there's only one of them,
so like,
you're supposed to share them with those
other people.
Yeah.
So you're in there with these cracked
out people.
Luckily I had three other hiking buddies
with me guys and the people,
granted they were aggressive towards
each other,
like they didn't bother us.
And,
and like I think by like 4:00 AM,
they hadn't gotten to sleep and we were
just like,
dude,
can you all please,
please be quiet.
Like I got to get some sleep.
And then,
uh,
um,
but that was the worst one.
Other than that,
I think everything was,
everything was pretty safe.
There's nothing too terrifying.
How did it play out?
Uh,
we left the next morning.
And did they eventually go to sleep?
Uh,
you know what,
I don't even remember.
I think at 4:00 AM,
I was so exhausted I was just like,
they were still yelling at each other.
I was just out,
you know.
And that was what they were yelling.
I was just this one of those shelters.
There you go.
Yeah.
That's one of them was looking little
place.
It's Kinda cool.
It's all made out of logs.
Yeah,
it's got kind of a tin roof.
Is that like a 10 sheet roof?
Uh,
yeah,
they vary a lot.
I mean you'll get all.
Would you sometimes won't even get logs.
Yeah,
there you go.
You can scroll up and see all the other
ones.
And those are for the hikers,
is that what they're for?
Yeah.
So that's.
So they've,
they've anticipated,
there's so many people that do this
trail that they've made these shelters.
I've heard of
these things in New Zealand.
Yeah,
too.
they have them and they stock food in
them and they leave a log so that hikers
can write down.
Like my friend Remy,
Remy Warren was in New Zealand and he
used one of those and like wrote in the
log,
you know,
where he was from when he was there.
And I guess it also helps identify if
people are missing.
Exactly,
yeah.
I think it's a safety precaution.
So if,
you know,
you can kind of track down where it was
the last person seen,
you know,
or wherever they last seen.
So if they were,
if they logged into a shelter and then,
you know,
they can't find them,
they can say okay,
on this date we know that they were here
so you can give a given radius and know
that if they are missing their within,
at least within a certain,
you know,
20 miles in distance walking distance of
their.
But yeah.
And I think those things actually turned
into like a just fun.
You know,
some people just go full on poems and
there some,
you know,
confess like life stories and they're
like,
Oh God,
yeah.
The trail log books are entertaining the
doubt.
Wow.
Here,
warning,
what does it say?
Harassing Baron.
Camp night of five,
11 swipe clause in two tents
stepped on my tent.
Tila collapsed on me.
Please be careful he didn't even try to
get the food hanging low on a branch
here.
Oh,
look at her name.
Flower passion flower with a sad face.
And there's another one.
Bear rip.
This is a different.
This is a different person's
handwriting.
Bear rip the bag hanging on my pack,
which was hanging on my hammock.
I was Muslim.
Say Bullshit.
Bouncing,
bouncing up and down.
He stole my toilet paper.
Exclamation point.
What does that say?
Subway.
That's his name.
Eat fresh.
Yeah.
Ps,
the pivot is great.
What's a pivot?
Are Pretty.
It's the a privilege.
It's just like an outhouse.
Oh,
compost.
Toilet.
How about this one?
Dat Shit cray all balls.
Ghetto Savior,
Baltimore.
All balls.
Ghetto Savior,
Baltimore.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Well you're dealing with like fringe
people,
right?
I mean these are people that are just
not fitting into the corporate module
very well.
They walked out on life a little bit.
Yeah,
a little bit.
Well you kind of did too,
right?
I mean you said you were an accountant.
Yeah,
I was an accountant in Birmingham,
so it was an accounting major and uh,
did that for about two years.
Um,
I mean the job was good and everybody
worked with I liked,
but I definitely was able to recognize
that there's not.
I was not going to be an accountant know
from my life.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think I knew it was going to do some
transition.
Try to get another job,
do something.
And the,
uh,
the ATU is kinda like,
this seems like the right thing to do,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm single at the time,
you know,
no kids a debt free,
like,
you know,
I didn't have a mortgage like time to
go,
so it just seemed like something this
radical because it's so crazy.
Committing to a six to seven month hike
was going to force you to just change
existence,
change your frequency,
the whole deal.
I mean,
you're a freak now.
You're,
you're wandering through the land
with all due respect.
Thanks dude.
I mean it's not a bad forever.
Like my best friends are freaks,
but it's,
I mean,
it's definitely a freak move,
right?
I mean,
no doubt.
Yeah,
well it's a,
it's a very strange subset of human
beings that don't not just drop out but
dropout.
And I mean,
you're,
you're committing to something that is.
I mean,
there was,
there ever a time we were like halfway
there we like,
maybe we just get a job in this fucking
town.
Uh,
and then some people did that,
you know,
I think that was more for financial
reasons.
It was like,
all right,
I gotta I gotta get some cash flow,
but a no man,
I think I definitely had kinda like a
grind mindset.
Like I'm gonna make it,
I'm going to make it,
you know,
and I think that yeah.
Did you go with a bunch of people
know?
Uh,
I think like 90 percent of hikers go on
eat alone and the fact that they're
just,
there are a lot of hikers out there,
surprisingly particularly going north.
You,
I think maybe 2000 people try to go
north every year.
Wow.
So when you're hiking,
there's like a gang of people on the
trail with you.
So,
but if you go south,
um,
it,
it changes every year,
but 10 to 15 percent of people that hike
the Antigo self,
it's like you're going to have much less
social circles,
stuff like that.
But in general,
you know,
people are hiking,
running like you're gonna meet people,
you're talking about the shelters,
like you're going to stumble into people
walking by,
you're going to meet them in town,
you're gonna meet him at the shelters
and they become your buddies.
You know,
like,
even I think the first,
the first night I was on the it.
Yeah,
I made good friends with two other
people and hiked with them for a couple
of weeks and then,
you know,
different paces.
You've made up different people.
You might hike with somebody for a
month.
Uh,
so it's Kinda like you just
hike for a little bit with some people,
you know,
for some given a time.
Wow.
What kind of weird stories are they
telling you about why they're out there?
I mean,
how many people are out there just like
duck in a murder wrap or something?
Was it,
um,
is it Eric Rudolph?
Which one was.
Hey,
Eric Rudolph didn't.
He ran out and eat and like he,
he was hiding out there for a long time.
Oh yeah.
He was like the unabomber.
No,
no,
that's,
that's not the unabomber.
The unabomber is Ted Kaczynski.
He's that guy that was in the park
bomber.
Oh,
okay.
So I believe it was Eric Rudolph was
found in a dumpster in North Carolina.
He had been hiding out,
like full on hiker,
homeless,
look,
beard grown.
But he had been,
you know,
hiding out on a t,
it seems like that would be a lot of
play,
a place where a lot of people get robbed
because you'd know that you have money
on you because you have to make this
trail,
you have to have some cash to buy food.
And
I never heard anything bad like that
happened.
Honestly.
I know that they're,
there have been a few murders on the 80.
Oh Shit.
But you think about,
think about any given city,
the murder rate,
you know,
it's like if you have 2000 through
hikers plus,
I mean 100,000 weakened hikers a year.
I mean more than that,
it's like the probability,
if you think about the 80 hikers as a
city,
like a murder every few years,
really it and in bed,
you know,
that's the same logic that they use for
those um,
foxconn buildings where the people jump
off the buildings where they're making
cell phones in China that go,
well,
you've got to think about how many
people work here.
Of course,
if you'd kill themselves,
it's just a game of numbers at that
point.
Right.
Somebody,
somebody's going to do it.
I guess it is.
So will you ever there when any of that
went down?
They were looking for a murder.
Know there was a famous case.
Oh,
I forgot her name.
Her hiker name.
Hold on her name flower.
All right.
So that's what passion flower was.
That's go to trail name.
Oh Geez.
Rappers.
Yeah.
So you get,
you get your
Dj Joe.
Yeah.
You get your trail name within,
I mean yeah,
within a week of being on trail within a
week.
Usually it's usually if you do something
monumental or stupid or something
noteworthy is going to give you.
You dubbed a name.
Wow.
Do you know my name?
Yes.
It was smooth.
Smooth,
smooth.
So I'd been in New Zealand prior to the
Aat and I had talked about not like
showering for a week at a time.
We're getting real personal here,
but I shaved my legs and I had shaved my
body here so I could just like wipe
down.
Okay.
And so when I came and ate at want to do
the same thing,
I was like,
I'm just going to shave my body here so
I can literally wipe down at night,
um,
and like check out for ticks,
like just made snakes and a.
and um,
yeah,
I was sitting right a fire early on,
like a couple of nights in and I'm
wearing my like,
sweaty legs for like,
glistening in the fire.
And some guy was just like,
dude,
do you shave your legs?
I'm like,
uh,
no.
Uh,
and then yeah,
smooth just came from.
That's a funny one man.
What a man makes a decision to shave his
legs.
That's how,
you know,
I never have,
I've shaved some body parts.
I've shaped my butt.
I'm sorry,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
I've shaved my butthole a two,
perhaps three times.
I just had this conversation with
someone about this the other day
because,
uh,
it's,
you know,
I'm Harry,
I'm a hairy dude other than the top of
my head.
But uh,
I get hairy and so it's not the best for
like keeping clean.
So one day I was shaving my package and
I said,
let's just get crazy,
let's go all the way down there,
finish it all.
And I did.
And one of the things I was shocked was
it changes the sound of your farts.
Did we talk about this on the podcast
before?
I've heard it discussed on another
podcast I talked about,
right?
Yeah.
It changes the sound of your farts.
They become more duck like.
Yeah.
It's like something about your butt hair
that muffles not that's the biggest
issue in the world,
but I'm also,
when they grow back,
it's quite unpleasant.
The grow back process,
like the itching and stuff,
you know,
there's something that happens when your
hair starts growing back when you're
like,
Hey,
I didn't think of this.
This isn't what I signed up.
Yeah.
But that's where I end.
I don't go through the legs,
but I'm not opposed to it.
It's not.
It seems to me like there's a problem
with why it's an issue,
you know,
like why is it an issue?
But I dunno,
there's something about,
is it a sexuality thing?
The Taboo?
Yeah.
Well,
why bring it,
bring it back to why is it okay to shave
your head?
Why is it okay to shave your face?
So get to shave all sorts and stuff.
But if you start shaving your armpits,
right?
Dudes that shave their armpits,
like,
hey,
what's going on?
My shaving your armpits.
You know,
why not?
What do you like where you're like hairy
armpits.
What's wrong with shaving your armpits?
There is something though.
If your friend yawned and you're like,
hey dude,
where the fuck is your armpit hair?
It would be an issue.
Right?
He started calling me like,
hey man,
she makes armpits weird flux of doing
it.
You know?
I know dudes that shave their legs
though,
but they're like super into fitness and
they're like,
you know,
you shouldn't be like as you want your
legs look good.
Right?
Yeah.
You don't want to like big,
sloppy,
fucked up looking legs that are shaved
also.
Then you let highlight like if you have
like these big,
like blocky tree trunk,
sloppy legs,
you'd want to keep them Harry.
That he looked like some sort of a bear,
you know?
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
There's something about like,
okay,
here's another thing.
Shave your eyebrows.
You shave your eyebrows.
Like who the fuck shaved their eyebrows.
It's weird,
right?
If you decide to shave your eyebrows,
people gonna just go.
You one of those guys.
Meanwhile,
just a couple inches south.
You Shave your mustache.
Nobody gives a shit.
Totally normal.
Seemed totally normal.
There's something about shaving those
eyebrows,
right?
That's true.
Yeah.
Or if you left your mustache and shaved
your eyebrows,
get the fuck away from me.
Kind of a Weirdo.
Are you?
We have weird rules.
Um,
what was the weirdest name that you
heard anybody get other than smooth?
Where to begin?
Um,
fart master.
I think that it's pretty self
explanatory how it got that one.
Uh,
one of my favorites was I got a buddy of
mine hiked with for a while.
His name was hover
job hovered,
hovered job.
He went to,
um,
when you get out of it and it's like
most people aren't even that familiar
with the woods,
right?
So you start trying to figure out tips
and tricks on how to do things.
So one of the things is how to use the
public facilities and uh,
he was saying he,
you know,
he does the hover job.
Oh yeah.
That's a good move.
Yeah.
Everybody knows that one,
right?
We stopped at some gas station somewhere
and you gotta take a shit.
You have to be really careful.
Yeah.
You don't want to test the sets that
sleep.
Now,
speaking of ticks,
you were talking about ticks.
Um,
I know lyme disease is a huge issue on
the east coast.
I saw something nearly day that was
saying this year is going to be a record
year,
some walnut hatching season something
and I don't know,
it was terrifying stuff.
I did this show back a while back on the
cipher.
I called Joe Rogan questions everything.
And one of the,
one of the things we talked about was
mostly conspiracy theories and it was
really interesting to find the mindset
of these conspiracy people and how
they're all very similar,
whether it's big foot or aliens or what.
They're really similar,
sort of bizarre mindset that the way
they look at things,
they hit this very compartmentalized,
fucked up way of looking at things.
But one of the ones that we studied that
was really fascinating,
something called more Jaylen's,
more gentleman's is a weird disease
where people believe that they have
these fibers growing out of their skin
and they start itching themselves and
they create these like lead Gen z
scratches.
And then things get attached to them
like fibers from like perhaps from a
carpet or something like that.
And they think that they're growing out
of their skin.
And most people think it's a
psychosomatic disorder.
But one of the guys that I talked to was
a doctor who also had more Jones.
And he was really a very objective about
it.
And he said there seems to be some sort
of a,
um,
neurotoxic effect that's connected to
lyme disease.
And he said that one of the things that
these people that have more gentleman's
have in common,
they almost all have lyme disease.
And what he believes is that ticks
contain not just lyme disease,
but a host of other different sort of,
uh,
diseases that you can catch.
And so because of these weird different
bacterias and different things that
these toxins that these ticks
potentially possess,
when you get bit by certain ticks,
you can actually hallucinate.
And he would say,
yeah,
he was talking about and we saw a thread
moving across his eyeball.
Wait,
this is real stuff.
That's of stuff.
No,
no,
no.
It's not sy stuff at all.
It's real.
People never even heard of this.
Yeah.
Well it's generally thought to be a
psychosomatic disorder.
And that's why it was interesting
talking to this doctor because he was
saying yes and no because he was saying,
well there isn't.
He believes there's a real issue and
that issue is lyme disease,
but that these pathogens that are in
these ticks,
they,
they're,
they're not,
it's not uniform.
There are different in all these
different ticks.
Some of them are more potent than others
and that there may be a host of
different unidentified pathogenesis.
There's not just lyme disease,
but several others.
And some of them have a neurotoxic
effect and this neurotoxic effect can
induce hallucinations.
And some of those hallucinations can be
that you think that your body's growing
fibers out of it.
And he,
he said that he saw it moving across.
Is it he goes,
I know intellectually that it was not
there.
He goes,
there was no,
I examined it.
I looked at it was not there,
but I saw it.
Is that he personally experienced the
notion.
Yeah.
And the other thing is a lot of these
people,
they go undiagnosed for long periods of
time because for the longest time a lyme
disease went undiagnosed and still does.
I have a good buddy of mine,
him and his son got bit by ticks when
they were fishing.
And uh,
he brought his son to the doctor.
And by then that bullseye,
you know,
around that grows or if you get bit by a
tick that has lyme disease,
there's like a bullseye.
It looks like the red circle that grows
around the area where the tick bit,
him and the Bulls.
I had gone away by the time he brought
him to the doctor.
So the doctor was incredulous and he's
like,
no,
I don't,
I don't believe that's lyme disease.
Kids from refined and then he started
getting bell's Palsy.
So half of his face was paralyzed and
that's when they really realized that
this,
Oh my God,
this kid has lyme disease for sure.
And then yeah.
And they were,
they were in real bad shape.
Like my friend who was skinny as it is,
he wound up losing something like 20,
30 pounds and it fucked with him for
close to a year.
The other guys that he was with,
uh,
they got lyme disease as well as several
people that were with got lyme disease
and they were all fucked up for months.
I knew one guy that got it and I think
he went to the doctor and got some shots
or antibiotics.
I don't know what the treatment was,
but he came back like full force and
finished the two.
Yeah,
you can't do that if you get,
if you get catch it,
like really clearly.
We had a guy on the podcast,
Steve,
Steve Kotler,
who got it,
and he was undiagnosed for over a year
and he wound up being bedridden for
three years.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Because the more it sinks into your
system,
the more you let it go or without
antibiotics,
without treatment.
And again,
with this doctor was telling me just
relaying what this one doctor who had
lyme disease was saying is that he
believes that there's a host of
different pathogens.
There's not just one and he,
he,
he said there could be many that are
undiscovered.
Like lyme disease is fairly recent in
terms of its discovery or our diagnosis
of it.
I feel like it's within the last two or
three decades at the most,
so I would worry about that.
We're out there.
The risk of the lyme disease on the
Appalachian trail is going to be high
this year.
Trail life.
Oh my God.
How do you retrain life when you're out
there?
You don't even have started.
Oh,
just came out today though.
Oh Shit.
They're talking about touching.
I didn't say that.
There was another
article and I googled lyme disease from
Connecticut that says that the testing
on found ticks with lyme disease is
higher this year,
more than normal for last year.
And repeat,
you get bitten when you go
flooding.
You can,
I mean,
I'm really careful,
real careful to check myself.
Also real careful to keep myself covered
up,
you know,
I wear gators.
I wear,
um,
you know,
a long,
like a Merino wool that goes all the way
down to my ankles and then I pull the
Merino wool socks way up over that.
I don't have any exposed up to my wrists
and I even wore gloves sometimes even in
the heat aware,
like a thin layer glove just to all also
it's good to protect your hands from the
sun but also to protect your hands from
the animals.
Seeing that white skin like you want a
little white as you can that's exposed.
But um,
I think about that primarily about ticks
scares the shit out of me.
Yeah.
Oh,
I wonder what percentage of ticks
actually carry because I feel like I've
probably been bitten by ticks in my
life.
You know,
some like,
I don't know what percent of the job I
got bit by a bunch when I was a kid,
um,
but I never got line but wasn't around
that much when I was a kid.
There was a thing about the New York
upper New York state area being
unbelievably infested.
Have you ever seen a lyme disease map?
Like a map of lyme disease infestation
in the northeast,
big time and this huge,
huge,
huge in the northeast and huge in New
York state like that upper New York
state area.
Just really,
really devastating.
I wonder whether that isn't related to
most.
I don't know.
Deer,
deer,
ticks apparently are a big issue.
Here it is.
Look at that.
There you go.
No,
it's the 2015,
but there's a few in California,
especially northern California has a
bunch,
but look at that fucking ne Man.
That's just like a Zombie plague.
That's awful.
Massachusetts is completely covered in
it.
Look at it.
The whole street.
New Jersey to covered.
Yeah,
but I'm just a devastating disease if
you don't catch it,
but guess it's spreading across the
country.
They're finding it in Florida now,
new strains in Florida.
What other issues do you have to deal
with when it comes to like bugs and
diseases and stuff like that?
Grd.
Uh,
oh yeah.
So what.
Yeah,
I was gonna ask you that.
How do you,
how do you get your water?
Like what are you getting?
There's a thing called,
um,
basically you all freshwater water
sources,
so streams,
lakes,
ponds.
Um,
unfortunately the east coast is,
it's so wet,
you know,
you're going to crossover water source
very frequently.
Generally several times a day you're
going to cross at least a stream.
So you fill up your water there.
Uh,
you carry two different containers to
two bottles,
one for dirty,
one for clean.
Uh,
so you fill up a leader of nerdy water
from the stream.
I'm a ton of different water methods.
I don't know if you do it in your back
country hunting,
but um,
the big one I use with saw your squeeze.
It's like a,
a nozzle.
You screw on top of your,
uh,
your water bottles he feel but dirty
water bottle.
Screw this water filter off and you
squeeze out clean water.
So that's what I used.
But I mean a lot of really works that
well.
You just squeeze it in.
The water comes out clean.
Yeah.
The filtration system,
is that good?
Yeah.
And it takes out Giardia.
Yes.
I think that kind of still standing.
But uh,
yeah.
And then they're like the droplets which
are basically a Columbian chemicals.
Right.
You know?
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
what else is there?
All sorts of filters and chemicals.
Some people try to boil it.
That's just a pain.
You don't want to boil water all the
time and then wait for it to cool down
before you get drink it.
Yeah.
I will say though,
by the end of the,
you talk about finishing and winter,
um,
you know,
it's like whenever you stop at these
freshwater sources,
you know,
the water's flowing and I'm,
it's like 20 degrees out,
15 degrees,
you know,
I'm like,
I don't want to stick my hand in that
freezing water and get my hands cold.
I can't hit them back up,
you know.
Um,
so I'll,
it admittedly,
not that I recommend this,
but I was,
I was drinking it straight,
man.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's risky.
It was risky,
but it was just like I was so done by
the end of it,
you know,
it's just like a,
I don't have the patients to stop with
freezing fingers,
like,
so numb,
you know,
the dexterity is just totally gone,
I'm like was just like,
wow.
So I'll see a doctor eventually.
And uh,
now when you,
when you got to the end seven months,
is that what it took you?
I think it was,
I got up trail for two weeks in between
there for some family stuff.
But uh,
if you took out that two weeks,
it was six months.
I was on trail.
So when you get off trail,
did you go fly somewhere?
Honestly,
I went to France with my family.
Whoa,
that's not,
doesn't count dude.
I.
And it was like,
oh,
just a human trash can.
I was just like cheese,
wine,
everything that I like I gained.
I gained at least five,
10 pounds that week and I was just like,
wow,
just pigging out showing joint the
shuttle.
That vacation though.
It was Kinda like that.
It was like,
you know,
a lot of guys are getting up jokes.
They're like,
Oh man,
I'm totally broken.
Everything,
like I'm going to France for a week or
two.
So some people get off trail just
because financially they can't hack it
anymore.
Yeah,
I mean you got a 19 year old guy who's
at a high school.
It doesn't have any savings.
It's like,
oh,
I'm going to go ahead with a two.
Sounds like a great idea.
They haven't done any research,
no planning,
don't know anything about gear or
anything,
but you know,
they've read a walk in the woods.
Um,
and I think this is a good idea.
It is a walk in the woods by Bill
Bryson.
It's probably the most popular book out
there.
It's like,
um,
it's just kind of a funny story.
He's a good writer.
Um,
but he wrote that I in like the mid
nineties.
But that book,
if you look at like the Appalachian
trail hikers,
it was just like put,
bup,
a walk in the woods is released.
I was like,
wow.
It was like huge publicity.
And if you heard of wild the book movie,
Reese Witherspoon.
No,
I,
yeah,
I did hear about it.
I never saw it.
But yeah,
that was,
was that a movie about the Appalachian
trail?
Pacific crest trail.
But it's,
that was the same thing.
It was like the eighties is so historic
and iconic for long distance hiking
trails that a walk in the woods did for
the 80 what wilde did for the Pacific
crest trail.
But wild is only released a few years
ago.
Um,
but I mean,
same thing,
it's like Pacific crest trail was
relatively unknown to hikers and that
book was released and an movie and it
was just like now Pacific crest trail is
really hot right now.
The Pacific crest trail though is the
one that goes from Mexico to California
and it goes all the way to Canada.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Top.
There's not that much water there.
No.
Right.
You talked about the east coast being
wet.
I think so what do they do there?
Uh,
my understanding is they have big,
um,
I don't know the terminology is a big
water reservoir,
like a big concrete cylinder out in the
middle of the,
uh,
of the desert and I don't know if it's
rain water or if somebody actually goes
out there and fills it up,
kind,
kinda like a trail trail.
Angel kind of goes out there and trail
angel.
That's another term to trail angel
take.
We'll take it.
We'll take a sidestep into.
It's just a trend is going to educate us
on the trail.
Angel,
go ahead.
Smooth.
All right.
Yeah,
we'll get,
we'll get an 18 dictionary going.
Um,
but yeah,
the trail angels in that term was um,
when you're hiking and eat,
you come to towns and you're like,
uh,
I need transportation to the grocery
store.
The grocery store is actually 10 miles
away from the trail crossing.
Like,
okay,
does that mean a hike 10 more miles down
the highway to get some groceries?
Then 10 more miles back.
No,
you hitchhike.
And then you hitchhike in town.
That's kind of that,
that person then becomes a trail angel.
Whoa.
But hitchhiking is fucking dangerous.
Have you ever done it?
Um,
maybe in the younger days.
Trying to think.
I definitely got rides from people when
my car broke down in,
in Massachusetts,
but I don't think I actually hitchhiked
like that was desperation without
intent.
Like I'm going to get a ride from
somebody.
No,
I never.
I never went out there and put my thumb
out and said I'm going to get from here
to there by hitchhiking.
Never do that.
You did?
Yeah,
you did.
You're,
you're a fairly young guy.
How old are you?
Twenty eight.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you're talking about within the last
10 years you hitchhiked a fair amount.
That's fucking crazy.
That's like when people already know
that hitchhiking is a good way to kill
folks.
Like if you want to kill somebody,
what do you kill some fucking kid with a
backpack.
That's the move,
right?
It's a great opportunity to kill or
above.
You're going to be one of those
Psychos,
you know?
I would just assume yeah,
everybody was pretty nice.
You know,
it's different parts of the country too,
you know,
like if you're going to go hitchhiking
in like New York,
you're gonna run into some really weird
people if you're like just outside of
Manhattan,
you got,
you thaw them out and you try and get
picked up.
You might get picked up by a fucking
complete psycho.
But if you're in Wyoming or something
and there's like no one out there and
you're hiking and
like rural Alabama,
Pennsylvania,
those crack heads screaming at each
other,
every other weirdos everywhere.
But will say like,
ah.
So before the [inaudible] in New Zealand
and New Zealand is higher standard of
living in the states and I feel like
you,
there's very low crime right there.
And hitchhiking is not taboo there.
I always heard that New Zealand was kind
of like the states,
uh,
was in the fifties and it was just like
Kinda like a,
a safe,
happy place,
you know,
there's no crime.
Everybody's nice to each other.
High standard of living.
And in New Zealand it was like they had
um,
some bus stops,
like the equivalent of like a bus stop.
And it was like a hitchhiking bench,
so you would sit there and like people
would drive on their way to work and
somebody will be sitting on the bench
like,
Hey,
pick me up,
you know?
But it's like systemized,
you know,
it's like people have hitchhike.
So it was like that.
The taboo was kind of broken in New
Zealand.
It was like,
this is normal,
people are,
it's an economical,
it's efficient.
Like why not,
you know,
but
it's not something I would ever do.
But man,
I remember I got my car,
my car broke down once in a snow storm
and these people took me back to their
house and they were so normal.
They were really normal people and they
made me that.
I was on my way to visit my girlfriend
and her mom and her drove to get me at
these people's house and I was in there.
I was driving up there and we just got
caught in a freak snowstorm car broke
down.
And I remember thinking like,
what kind of person?
Just pick someone up and takes them to
their how they're so nice.
Let's be a Weirdo.
But no,
they were really nice,
they were really nice people.
They just took a chance,
you know,
I guess the fear comes from that like
point,
oh,
one percent,
right.
That's going to do something with like a
vast majority or you know,
why not?
I'm just looking to help somebody out.
It was like something with like airbnb.
There was that fear.
It was like,
oh,
there's no way I could let somebody come
into my house or couchsurfing.
Couchsurfing is,
it's like,
um,
airbnb for free.
Essentially.
You put up your couch on this website
and you offer.
Um,
yeah,
see,
like I've got a couch,
does anybody want to stay on it?
And then you say,
I'm coming through on these dates and
your request the couch for free.
But it's like,
remember that when that website was
really becoming popular about 10 years
ago,
people had that same idea.
I was like,
no way.
This is only for nutjobs.
Like it's hugely popular now.
And airbnb and all that stuff's like,
yeah,
let somebody come and stay in your house
and meet travelers.
Share authentic travel experiences as
opposed to what?
Fake travel experiences.
Fuck,
does that mean authentic?
Meet New People,
explore the world,
go on a rape binge,
find a couch.
I'll find a host.
There's a couch.
Is a graphic of a couch.
So this is.
What is this?
What is this website?
Jamie?
Couchsurfing.com.
Yeah.
What?
But that's what's crazy is that somebody
decided to organize this.
They decided to make a website.
Every year we support 400,000 hosts,
4 million surfers.
I love.
I call them surfers.
Isn't imaginary or real surfer.
And you heard this like,
listen,
bitch fucking surf or you don't even
have to balance your laying down some
dudes couch hundred thousand events.
They support a 100,000 events.
This is crazy.
I never knew about this.
Yeah,
I mean they're also like niche websites
that have another one.
Uh,
scroll down Jamie.
That image.
Warm showers is another one.
That's first cyclists.
Look at that guy like updating the top
of the world.
Ready for your next adventure.
Planet trip.
Stay on my couch.
It's very strange in Paris.
You can go surf and look in Paris you've
got find food and wine and cheese and
bread.
You can afford that.
You can't afford a fucking hotel room.
Let's see.
That's like a fucking expensive meal
right there.
Looking at some really delicious food.
It's very,
uh,
strange because it's a very
romanticized,
like this is really organized.
This website's super well done.
Local hosts and they have avatars of
images,
reviews.
Oh my God,
look,
it's Louis joined couchsurfing to see
loses full profile.
It's free
about me.
Current mission.
Can I host one person only?
Wow.
This is weird.
You can put your ketchup.
Do.
Nope.
That's not gonna happen.
But it is interesting.
I mean it's like,
it's the good aspects of it are,
I'm sure far outweigh the negatives.
You know,
most people are just enjoying
themselves.
Meeting nice people,
meeting like minded people,
traveling around.
Like my feet are obviously humor aside,
but my fears are probably fairly
unfounded.
Right.
But isn't that kind of how it is with
life like most,
most people that you meet,
like the vast majority of people are
really pretty nice.
Like this is all intention.
It's a really safe time to be a person,
you know?
I mean,
almost all interactions you have with
people on a daily basis are safe and
fairly friendly.
Even like rude people are like,
well,
what's the big deal?
They say a word,
you know,
like most.
Yeah.
Most.
Almost nothing happens most of the time,
but we're so obsessed with the news
where you tune into any news channel,
all you're getting is the collective bad
news of 7 billion people because that's
what sells.
If it bleeds,
it leads run with it.
Mike.
Mike runs with it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean this is,
that's actually a very.
When you really look at it that way,
that's a very positive trend that people
are doing this hosting,
hosting people,
shared shared economy.
What's this?
That's really nice.
You know,
it's nice that people will offer up
their couch for free.
Yeah,
it's good stuff.
It is good stuff.
So do you ever stop and think like what
if I hadn't gone on this journey of
exploration and I stayed in the
accountant and you would be living that
life of the droning existence where
every day he just fucking Sean over the
same place,
crunching numbers and hating life and
wishing for some kind of adventure,
something different.
No,
I can't,
I can't relate to.
I think no matter what,
whether it's 80 or something,
I think I would have,
you know,
I'm too impatient,
I get bored too easily.
Something,
you know,
I would have done something
then a lot of people don't.
A lot of people are like you and they
just never make that move.
They never,
they never take that chance.
So yeah,
I think when I talked to even a lot of
my friends that are still doing,
I'm not going to call them crappy jobs,
but you know,
because I think they do provide a lot of
things that they like,
you know,
security.
You can't.
Some people love that security,
getting a paycheck,
you know?
Um,
but it's like,
I don't think they view it like that.
It's not like,
oh,
this may not be the best thing,
but I like it,
you know,
it's not like A.
I don't know.
It's like some people think this is so
bad or I,
I just can't.
I just have to like,
I just don't think that,
that,
that threshold ever crosses most people,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
people very,
the personality types that go on that
trail.
I mean that's like a very,
very extreme personality type,
but I think most people have a certain
amount of,
if not wanderlust,
at least curiosity.
It's just a matter of how much of it do
you,
how much of it do you nurture?
How much of,
how much of that that needed to feed
this.
Also,
there's also a real problem than not
recognizing the finite nature of
existence.
You know,
I mean just when you're 20 especially or
21 or whatever it is,
when you enter into these jobs you don't
realize like,
hey man,
you've only got like a few decades.
Right?
Have a good time.
You could do this for 40 years easily.
Oh,
easily,
easily.
And then we've all met those people that
have done it for 40 years and they just
beaten down by life and they have that
dull,
desperate look in their eyes.
It's just the sadness in their eyes
where their life is just.
It's not,
it's not good.
It hasn't turned out well.
There's not a lot of joy there.
Yeah.
And hold onto the vacations.
Big Time.
You're scaring the shit out of me,
Chris.
Scaring the shit out
of me.
So you in the middle of doing all this,
right?
So you do this,
you go on this crazy seven month
adventure and when it's over,
what was that like when you,
when you hit the end and you realize
they're like a bell,
you ring or anything like that.
She put a bell up there.
So going north,
but there's,
there's like,
there's like this epic Mountain Qatada
and it's like a beautiful big mountain.
I'm one of the,
like the most epic climbs that's in
Maine.
So if you go south,
you end in Georgia and you end on
Springer Mountain,
which is just not as,
not as that,
but God is dramatic.
You know,
you're right.
So,
but yeah,
I mean you finish it,
there's just a plaque and it's like,
dude,
you finished really?
And you touch the plaque,
you have to touch it.
What does he get right before and you
quit right before like a flint before
the fuck this.
Just gloves for the plan.
Yeah,
that's it.
So that's good.
That's the main.
That's the,
that's the finish and finish.
And uh,
yeah,
north bounders.
How many people fake it?
Take a picture of that dude.
Dude,
you can go hike that in one day.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's usually,
at least I would probably do that.
I'd go hike it in a day and then get
that weird feeling of watching these
people that are covered in two inches of
grime.
Climb up that hill.
Can you pull up spraying that guy?
That motherfucker.
Look at that guy.
That guy looks like he's been hiking for
seven months.
Hecker Springer Mountain.
Look at that guy's face.
Jesus Christ.
He's just all hair.
And
so,
um,
there you go.
Yeah,
that's the uh,
that's where it starts.
Is that the gateway?
That's,
that's what's called the approach trail.
It's not the,
I'm like,
well I kinda has like a,
an on.
That's the actual plaque on the end,
but that's not a great shot of it.
There you go to.
So that's where it starts.
Yep.
National scenic trail.
Now who established this?
Uh,
so the kind of in Benton Benton,
MCI.
I'm trying to talk people into doing
that with you.
Like when you first started doing that,
like what year did this guy do this?
I know I know these dates,
but I don't think they can guarantee 30
days.
So imagine 19 thirties.
Fucking great depression that all deal.
Those are the people back then and this
guy says,
I know what do,
I'm going to walk all the way up to
Maine and I'm going to start a whole
movement.
A bunch of other people going to do as
well.
Like,
fuck you dude.
And get a job.
Hippie.
Yeah.
The CCC at the time was helping
construct all the uh,
the trails at that Springer Mountain,
Georgia.
Eight point five miles mount.
How to say it?
Catoctin catoctin main 2000.
One hundred and eight point five miles.
Those point five or a motherfucker that
last point five.
Oh,
so when you did it and you touch the
sign and you're like,
all right,
I did it.
I cried.
Did you?
I did.
I literally clubs.
Wow.
Well you failed you knees.
It was like,
it was seriously one of the most
emotional times in my life.
I couldn't imagine.
I was just,
yeah.
Even even like that morning I woke up
and I was just like,
oh my gosh,
this is,
this is ending,
you know,
it was like so much,
just so long.
I had been thinking about it from.
Yeah,
I mean childhood,
you know,
and then it was like not only thinking
about it for a decade,
but then it was actually hiking the darn
thing for six months and it was just
like getting there.
But that time,
like I had stress fractures forming and
my feet and uh,
yeah,
I was just in bad shape.
I wasn't sleeping well because,
you know,
at night it was going to get into zero
degrees every night and my sleeping bag
was not cutting it.
So it's just like,
it was just a lot man,
you know,
stress fractures in your feet,
huh?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I,
I've had had stress fractures from cross
country in high school,
so I knew what they felt like,
oh,
this is coming.
It's just a matter of time,
you know.
Now what kind of hiking shoes did you
wear?
Okay.
We,
it seems like your gear would be
critical big time.
Yeah.
Uh,
I started off with a brand called
Selayla.
They were kind of like a technical
climbing shoe actually,
but um,
the fact that they are a little more
stiff,
exactly.
Um,
makes them good for some tough,
tough trail.
But uh,
I switched to a trail runners and I
don't do run.
Yeah,
I started reading really,
really recently,
like a few days.
I think I saw you post something on
facebook.
You had a rough,
a rough run,
fucking terrible at it.
A bit like a bowling ball.
It's not good for running some weight,
want to keep doing this.
But yeah,
I've been running for a few days now.
But uh,
yeah,
I switched to um,
basically just running shoes with the
little thicker tread,
like Solomon's Solomon's is a great
brand.
I got those for the very purpose of
running up hills.
You like them?
Yeah,
it seemed good.
They've got good traction to them.
Could tread like a thick tread,
but yet there are still built like a
running shoe.
It was a good hiking shoes.
Something that you can breathe and give
you some cushion and you don't need any
ankle support,
you know,
feel.
I feel like that's overrated
mountaineering thing.
Yeah.
I think there's kind of this theory that
your ankles toughened up.
Um,
I don't know if that's really true,
but I think I kind of fell into that
belief that I was rolling ankles so much
in the first 100,
200 miles of the trail and by the end of
it was just like,
just keep going,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I've always wondered about that because
a lot of people that hunt,
they were these like really stiff,
very tactical mountain hiking boots
where they,
uh,
they go out that,
you know,
they go like 10 inches up the ankle and
they lace them up tight.
Yeah.
I say when I used to go hunting with my
dad when I was a kid and we would,
we would wear those boots and uh,
looking back I'm like,
Eh,
I don't get it.
And is it just because maybe the brush
is just so thick you need something like
durable to cross through that brush.
It's like,
I don't think so.
What do you mean?
What do you wear when you go hunting?
Well,
it varies.
I've never worn.
I'm running shoes like those,
like trail running shoes,
but I know some people do do,
do wear those and they like them and
some really good hunters.
They were them exclusively.
There were like lightweight trail
runners and they,
and even Solomon actually makes a gator
for those trail runners so that you can,
for people to know what a gator is.
Gators like a thing that you slip over
your shoes and it cinches down tight so
that rocks and dirt and stuff doesn't
get deep into your shoe.
Um,
and I think who you is coming out with a
boot that actually has a gator built in
was kind of interesting,
but they could see the salomon trail
gaters yeah.
See,
so the idea is to make sure that you're
not getting irritants,
dirt and shit and debris.
Did you ever wear anything like that
when you were?
Definitely,
yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Is that a,
is that a must have some hikers?
I'd say kind of roll their eyes at it.
I started off rolling my eyes at it and
then it was just like you're saying it
was just good.
I mean five times a day I would get a
little pine needle in my sock and it's
just like,
oh damn it.
Like,
yeah,
I got to get something to keep that
going out.
So I would imagine that you would have
an incredible ability to test gear.
Like nobody would probably know what
gears effective and durable and really,
really like over the longterm.
Yeah,
totally.
And it's like,
I mean,
a part of the Ata,
I'd been backpacking for over 10 years
and I thought I was kind of okay,
I'm pretty familiar with this stuff.
And I was like,
no,
I didn't know anything about
backpacking.
And Yeah,
you test everything,
you know,
and it's like even even after all your
research,
you start realizing like,
hmm,
there's a little bit better stuff out
there or yeah,
I can actually tweak this and improve
this and that.
But yeah.
But at the end of it,
it's like anybody was through hike.
This can get into some real nerdy
backpacking gear talk,
you know,
hunters get into real nerdy backpacking
gear talk when they talk about like deep
in the woods,
back country hunting because weights
initiative,
huge issue.
They chop the ends off of their
toothbrushes,
you know,
that's like a big issue with you.
You did that to big time.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Like the idea that the bottom of your
toothbrush every ounce,
man,
that's fine.
You won't ounces equals pounds,
right?
Yeah.
So that was one thing that got cody and
I talked to him was cody was talking
about cutting,
cutting weight from backpacking.
I feel like my impression,
at least when we were talking,
I was thinking hunters.
We're almost kind of the,
the Chubby guy in the blind.
It was kind of my idea.
I was like,
when my dad and I would hunt,
it was Kinda just truly sitting there
with blue jeans and it was just kinda
like,
all right,
there's a duck,
you know,
it was like talking to cody,
I think hunting I was doing was pretty
amateur and it was.
Cody was talking about cutting weight
significantly in that.
Hunters have kind of latched onto some
of the backpacking,
you know,
ethos,
if you will,
about shaving every ounce.
But it's like y'all carry so much more
gear.
Like you got weapons,
you know,
like that's.
Those things aren't made to count every
ounce I would imagine we had.
Depends on what you caring.
But there are some lightweight rifles
that people use so that are like carbon
five barrels and stuff.
But the issue with those is they,
unless you're like prone and you're
laying
down on something,
they move a little bit more and a lot of
people think they're not as accurate as
like a real heavy rifle.
Like a lot of guys.
Sacrifices.
Yeah.
They look a heavy rifle,
like a heavy barrel,
thick,
heavy barrel.
And the same thing was bose.
That's a weird thing.
Like some people like heavy bose because
it's usually you hold steadier,
you know,
there's the thought behind it that you
have something light in your hand and
you're shaking a little bit.
Like maybe you're a little nerves,
he might move around a little bit more,
but if you've got something that's
stable,
he heavy,
you know,
you'll have more stability when you're
executing the shot.
But killer equipment to.
Yeah,
a lot of guys carry spotting scopes and
15 power by nose and they have eight to
10 power by nose around their neck.
And
you know.
Yeah,
depends on what kind of stuff you use.
You know,
some people,
they'll sacrifice,
uh,
like spotting scopes.
They won't do that,
they won't bring it.
But some people were,
some people also want to film other
stuff,
so they bring tripods for filming and a
tripod for glassing glassing meaning you
know,
lock,
uh,
either by [inaudible] or a spotting
scope on a tripod,
so you get a real steady view because it
really makes a difference.
Like if you see more animals,
yeah,
if you're holding up like the
[inaudible] in your hand,
you got to Kinda like put your elbows on
your knees and you sit down.
But it's not as good like being on a
tripod,
so the best way for sure.
But then you got carry the equipment,
you've got to carry that fucking tripod
around.
And there's,
I think there's a big difference between
people that they carry their stuff in
and then they make a camp versus people
to keep their camp on their back all the
time.
There's a lot of that too.
There's different kinds of hunting.
Like,
dude,
do you know that ever took bag?
Wait,
I think cody was mentioning it was like
60 or 70 pounds.
Do you have any idea?
Yeah.
A lot of guys will carry in 60,
70 pounds.
That's pretty standard,
but again,
they're not.
These guys are not carrying their camp
on their back just.
But if they do like if they know they
have to go in deep and they have to live
off their back.
Like they have a Bibi Bibi tent and
they,
they do the whole thing off their back.
Most guys would try to drop it in the
forties,
but if you carry around 40 fucking
pounds,
man,
like there's a company called the
outdoorsman and Phoenix and they make
like a real high end pack and one of the
things that they've made that they
actually just sent me,
it's a pack frame that has like an
Olympic plate mount on it.
So you can put like a 45 pound plate and
another 45 pound platelet and 90 pound
plate and you train with his fucking
pack frame on.
So you put the frame on.
You mean like a little,
like a weight lifting,
like lifting slides onto your back the
same way with slide onto the end of a
barbell and it,
you know,
use a clamp,
like a,
like a barbell clamp locks the plate in
place,
and then you go up hills and these
fucking things on.
So these guys are just trending.
Yeah,
they're training to get ready for these
back country hunts.
I had the same idea as you did.
I thought hunters like,
oh,
duck dynasty guys.
They're all fat.
Right?
And they just rednecks.
They're shooting at Shit.
No,
not western hunting is a big difference
between the southern hunter.
Yeah.
Well there's a big difference between
blind hunting,
like people that sit in these blinds
when blind is,
is like for people listening is like,
it's basically like a little structure
that's covered with like Cammo and
you're,
you're hiding,
waiting for the animal,
and then you shoot them or tree stand,
same thing.
You're sitting in the tree stand,
you're waiting and then you shoot them.
There's a big difference between that
and these western hunters,
particularly like elk hunters because
they're going into the mountains where
these animals live or mule deer,
they're going to the high country and
you're climbing up,
you're going up thousands of feet of
elevation every day up and down,
up and down,
and you have to have massive endurance.
So a lot of these guys start trail
running.
A lot of these guys start putting packs
on their back with,
with heavyweights in the pack and
training,
getting ready for this.
Otherwise you're fucking miserable.
If you're not in a real shape,
you're miserable.
You know?
Got a good foot.
You got to get a real fit.
Interesting.
Yeah,
that's not what it is.
Well,
my friend Cameron names,
he does a lot of ultra marathons.
He just,
he just did the big foot 200,
which is 205 miles in Washington state.
How long has it to 78 hours.
He ran for seven,
eight hours.
Wow.
Fuck everything about that will.
Right.
But,
but that just shows,
you mean he's as extreme as it gets.
You know,
he's like one of the top bowhunters in
the world,
but the point is these people are
athletes,
the w,
the,
the ca in the group of them,
the elite of the elite there,
so few.
It's a really,
really small club of individuals that
get to that point,
but the vast majority of them are in
spectacular shape where they're
constantly running trails.
There are constantly working out.
They're constantly in shape and the
reason being is if you're not,
you're not going to be successful in the
back country.
And one of the things that really haunt
them is when they can't get to an animal
because they're out of shape.
And I've been there before.
I've tried that where I was like,
well,
when I was last year I was hunting with
cam and we went up,
we're trying to get to this elk,
and he ran up the hill like a fucking
mountain goat and I'm halfway behind
them.
I thought it was in pretty good shape
and I am for the stuff I do,
but I wasn't in good shape for running
up hills.
You know,
you gotTa,
you gotta do that to be in shape for
running up hills.
You've got to run up hills and a lot of
these guys there,
they have these uh,
events,
these,
uh,
trained to hunt events that they do
where they compete against each other
and they put backpacks on and they run
and they,
they,
they try to get from point a to point b
faster.
There's a lot of people are criticizing.
You think it's kind of dangerous and
it's because it's not really running
with weapons.
What is the interest about it?
Wait,
you're talking about still about the
barbell.
The barbell things is completely new and
ventured by the outdoorsman.
It,
it hasn't even come out yet,
but most people just pack heavyweights
like sandbags and strap down at their
backpack.
But uh,
it's,
it's a different world as far as like
the perception of what these people are
versus what they're actually doing.
And there's a real ignorance when people
are talking about hunting,
they think of it as like this really
easy thing.
You just go shoot this animal.
And they think the hunters are cruel
because that's what bad thing that
killed Bambi and you know what I mean,
like this is weird ideas that people
have in their head about what hunting
is.
And I think in general that was kind of
my impression of the,
uh,
I guess,
I don't know if easy is the right word,
but yeah,
not,
not physical.
Certainly enough physical.
No one would think from the outside
without really examining it and looking
in that you're talking about like elite
endurance athletes.
But if you took the average person that
thinks they're in shape,
and I have friends that have done this
before,
taking people that think they're in
shape and take them on these hunts.
And these people break down slug.
Yeah.
They just can't make it.
They can't do it.
They just,
they're just not prepared for it.
And it's hard to prepare.
And there's,
they say there's very few things you can
do other than put weight on your back
and go up,
go up and down hills and just do it.
Yeah.
Some people say boxes,
you know,
steps,
those things.
Like when people step up with one leg at
a gym,
you know,
and they,
and they do that over and over again.
Some people say that that's a good way
to prepare for,
for hiking as well.
Just box steps over and over again,
like commit to the.
Yep.
Yeah,
just get those quads.
I run,
I'm weird.
Weirdly in some ways.
Um,
trail bikes apparently very good like
doing dirt bike because you're
constantly pumping one leg at a time and
apparently that is very good for
mimicking the type of strength that you
need to get up.
And down hills goes back to like what
you said about just doing it though.
It's was like,
yeah,
just do it,
you know,
it sucks though,
man.
I did it the other day.
I did a five mile hike or four mile hike
and uh,
one of the,
the whole one of the miles I did with my
daughter who's 50 pounds and from a mile
up the hill I carried her on my back.
So she worked.
She got tired and so,
uh,
I put her on my shoulders and I carried
her one mile straight up hill on my back
and all my God,
I was drawn ranched.
I mean my jet,
my Hoodie,
I was wearing a hoodie.
It was soaked to the bone,
put sweat was pouring down my head.
I was heaving as I was carrying her,
you know,
it's really interesting how difficult it
is because just the hike,
it's kinda difficult,
but I could do it because I'm in pretty
good shape.
But the hike with a
50 pound kid on your shoulders fucking a
thousand times harder of A.
Yeah,
it's hard.
But I,
uh,
but I used it as a workout and she's
like,
if you're too tired you can stop.
Like,
no,
it's a good workout.
It's good.
It's good for me.
You know,
it was probably freaked her out here.
Maybe go
carrying or like thinking I'm going to
fall or something like that.
But it wasn't,
wasn't dangerous.
Like it wasn't like I was,
my legs were failing,
but I was breathing fucking heavy,
that's for sure.
So you've got to imagine these guys that
are carrying 20 pounds more than that
and they're carrying their weight deep
into the mountains,
you know,
or the pack out.
That's the other thing.
When you kill an animal,
like you've got 100 pounds on your back
now and you've got to slowly but surely
make your way in.
A lot of guys get seriously injured
during this.
Let's say,
what do you do to drag it?
You put it in your backpack.
One hundred pound animal
[inaudible] yeah,
we'll know much more than a hundred
pound animal.
Usually any deer you shoot is going to
be more than 100 pounds and an elk is
way more than a hundred pounds.
So what you're doing is you're making
multiple trips with 100 pounds on your
back.
The heck it up.
Yeah.
You have to chop it up.
Now when it comes to like backpacks and
things along those lines,
like what?
How do you choose what kind of backpack
you need?
And like you,
you must have like a weight
consideration as well.
And as far as volume,
like how much stuff you need.
You said you carry one change of
clothes,
so you basically have one pair of socks,
one pair of underwear,
one pair of pants,
other than stuff you have on,
right,
you bring a change of shoes,
um,
you typically break it up by activity so
you have,
um,
hiking and sleeping,
so you have your hiking set of clothes
and gear and then you have your
sleeping.
So hiking clothes are usually like a,
just like maybe like workout clothes,
like a synthetic,
short sleeve top,
maybe even running shorts,
um,
and you know,
a set of socks to hike in and then your
trail runners to hike in.
Um,
it's Kinda like you're hiking attire,
you know,
I'm certainly not like the pant hiking
boot kind of image.
I think that's,
that's,
you know,
going away.
And then you have your sleeping set of
closed your camp clothes,
which is a typically like a very
minimalist camp shoe.
It's all about weight because that's,
that piece of footwear is on your back,
right?
So you want to make sure that one's
light,
you know,
so a lot of people even used crocs.
I know these crocs because it's super
light,
it's light and it's waterproof and walk
around camping.
Um,
and then,
um,
you know,
some kind of wool,
like honestly this,
I love this book,
a Merino Merino wool,
something warm to sleep in something dry
like that.
Those clothes,
like get your hiking clothes,
wet,
dirty all day long,
but when you come home or when you get
to camp at night,
it's like,
keep it,
make sure it's comfortable,
make sure it's drugs.
That's your saving grace if you have to
go to sleep in wet clothes and
wintertime,
like,
that's no good.
Yeah.
Now why,
uh,
why synthetic?
Why do you choose synthetic?
So I know a lot of people choose Marino
for,
for hiking as well because it regulates
temperature.
Well,
and when it's wet you could still stay
warm.
Uh,
I think you,
I mean,
you can have arguments on both sides.
Uh,
I personally like synthetic just because
I feel like it dries faster and it's a
little more durable like this is,
this would just tear,
you know,
and it's like,
I like getting down and dirty when I
hike and I'm like a synthetic shirt even
just from Walmart,
you know,
nothing,
nothing amazing.
Just delights lightweight since the
synthetic shirt.
Um,
I think it was just going to breathe and
uh,
um,
yeah,
dry faster,
but I mean marina marina to and what
kind of package using a man I could
totally nerd out on packs.
I did it.
I used an osprey on actual 80 a hike.
I don't want to talk bad about Osprey
spray spray a lot,
but I would not hike with them again and
I do,
um,
how come a hate to be,
you know,
kind of,
um,
from aesthetics,
but I just don't like the way they look.
Got This,
they've got this like,
um,
that seems like the last thing that you
consider when you're wearing crocs,
but that's true.
But they have this,
um,
they kind of pride themselves and
breathable back.
Do you know what?
I'm know that was pretty like they have
like that concave back and it just feels
like a,
like a turtle shell as can't stand it.
It's like,
I feel like I'm like falling back with
it.
Okay.
So the weight's not tight to your back.
Yeah.
I want something snug on my back.
Um,
I guess that's not.
I mean it's a little utility.
Not that's a big issue for utility.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
You just think they look weird to.
Exactly.
It's like,
I don't like it looks bizarre.
Like what's the name of the practice?
We can pull it up a osprey.
Exos.
Fifty eight.
Um,
and so that's 5,800 liters.
Is that what it is?
It's 58 liters.
Fifty eight liters.
Liters.
Yeah.
And then um,
but um,
if I were to do it again,
there are a handful of pretty bad ass
ultra light pat companies.
It's kind of,
you've got this bell curve of like
Osprey is like the majority of
backpackers and it's like you get into
like that niche ultra light and then
you've got like a handful too.
There.
It is appealing.
Yeah.
That's it.
So that's a,
just looks like a space in between the
back.
Right?
I'm not into that.
So that's just for breathability.
Yeah.
But it's like,
man,
you're sweaty pig.
No matter how you look at it,
I just don't,
I just don't see the argument for
breathability back there.
There's some people like it.
Definitely.
So it's just a,
it's maybe personal preference.
Yeah.
So what is like,
what's the elite of the elite?
Uh,
I could,
I would probably say like four.
There's a hyperlink mountain gear,
uh,
they make.
What's a Cuban fiber?
Do you know?
Cuban fiber,
the material,
Cuban,
Cuban fiber.
It's called Dyneema now.
It's okay.
I've heard of Dyneema Dyneema for um,
both strings.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
but it's lightweight,
strong on.
They're super expensive.
Hyperlight mountain gear mix.
I like their packs.
Gossamer gear.
They make great packs,
a little more affordable.
Super lightweight granite gear.
It's another one.
And then ula equipment,
was it probably be the four pack
companies I'd,
uh,
I'd want,
I'd want to use for the next cycle
would,
if there's a,
is there a cost,
not an option.
Best best one or is it just all four of
them are really similar.
Even the guy,
the gossamer gear,
Mariposa,
that's a model.
They're probably more affordable than
some of the other options.
I'd probably like it the most.
So yeah.
Even even if money wouldn't,
you know,
money wasn't an issue there,
so one of the more affordable packs and
make the best.
What's interesting about pacs is a lot
of it is like where it centers the
weight on you and you can make one pack
with the same amount of weight would
feel lighter than another pack just by
the way it's designed and the way the
load lifters work and all that jazz and
your torso length,
like you know what fit you might not fit
me.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
I went backpacking with my girlfriend.
I gave her some of my pecs and her torso
just so much shorter than mine.
Like the hip belt wasn't working
properly so she can rest the weight on
her hips and then it's all on her
shoulders and then she's like,
God,
this sucks.
And I'm like,
that's one of the best picks up there,
you know.
So do you have to,
can you adjust it for her or is it just
needs a bit different path?
I did different.
You need different says hm.
That's interesting.
So how do you know what to choose?
You have to just try them out.
Uh,
I would.
Yeah.
And to try them out.
And it's hard to do because like your
local Rei,
um,
I don't know if
they don't carry those kind of niche
ultralight Pepsi can't go try them on.
They care,
they'll carry on,
they'll carry osprey.
Yeah.
Good.
Try him on measure torso link.
Some of those online retailers have ways
to measure your torso length,
makes sure it fits right.
But still at the end of the day,
it's like a pair of shoes.
You gotta you gotta try them on.
You know,
it's interesting because hunters in
general do not use the same packs that
backpackers use.
Probably more holsters and all sorts of
stuff you need.
Your needs are different I would
imagine.
Right?
Yeah,
for the most part.
But a lot of it is like certain things
you strapped to the pack,
like you strap your boat or your pack
and some of them have like rifle
holsters or rifle,
you know,
scabbards that you can kind of contain a
rifle and like a lot of them have a
little packets or air areas.
We get strapped down and tripod or maybe
the top compartment you would keep your,
your binoculars or something along those
lines.
But I would think that there would be
like a lot of crossover and there's not.
There's exclusive sort of segment of the
population or of the market rather.
Why is that?
Is it just marketing it?
Just targeting different audience?
I don't know because I wouldn't think
that that would be the case because it's
not the case really with boots that much
as a lot of people use like Solomon's
and really standard hiking boots.
There are hunting boots like crispy and
Kenna track and there's a few of those
that are like specifically designed
[inaudible] snake.
Like people use using for other things
too,
but they're like really well known in
the hunting world.
Maybe the markets will start blending,
I wonder,
but I'm just wondering like you would
think you would go to those guys,
the backpackers,
the,
the Appalachian trail people like they
would have already done the work.
I would think that that's the people to
contact.
They know what's good.
Yeah.
They're traveling for seven fucking
months.
You,
you know?
No.
Do you take like a nalgene bottle or
something like that with you?
Like smart water bottles?
Smart water.
That's it.
Really?
Yeah.
Like,
I mean these water bottles are fine.
Um,
but uh,
I like smart water because you talked
about that filter then sell your
squeeze.
We were talking about it.
It matches water bottle threads.
But the problem like with like this
bottle specifically is it goes around
what,
like two and a half,
maybe one and a half times around.
It's like smart water bottles.
This piece is about that long and it's
just like much,
much better.
It's much more secure so it's like more
threads threads to,
to secure it.
So.
So there's not gonna be any,
any leak or anything.
It's crazy to think that that all you
have to do is squeeze the water,
like how long does it take to do like a,
a one liter thing of water and that's
the biggest,
that's the biggest con with that
specific type of filters.
The fact that you have to manually do it
and it can take awhile.
So if you had a group of,
let's say you wanted to go with your,
with your kids backpacking,
like I don't know if I'd recommend that
filter because you're gonna have to
squeeze all their water through that one
little filter,
but if it's just you and you're trying
to squeeze a half a liter,
a liter at a time,
like it's fine.
You know,
might take a minute.
I've seen those gravity filters to.
Yeah,
like who you're going with your family
or something and you have to do more
volume of water.
I'd probably go gravity filter.
So here it is right here.
Okay.
So your squeeze water filtration system,
there's a video of it.
Oh,
okay.
And it squeezes into a bag.
So you fill the water bottle up and then
you squeeze it.
And then it fills that bag.
So do you use one of those?
Um,
so the manufacturer bag.
Oh,
I see.
Do you use one of those tubes?
Oh,
so what is it?
What's going on right there?
That's the clean water coming out.
I see,
I see.
Oh,
so that's it.
Huh?
So you fill the bag up and he squeezed
that thing and then it comes out the
end.
Wow.
It's pretty good stuff.
It's amazing that that's all you have to
do.
I would think there's a bunch of bears
shitting in that water.
Like what are the odds that you could
just do that?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I think they're marketing more towards
like,
um,
know like Africa and stuff.
No.
All right.
If you get,
if you have a water source that's
polluted,
like you can start to get water for
village,
you know,
it's like just squeeze it through in the
head like a warranty of uh,
some,
some insane amount of water can go
through there,
you know?
And then what do you do?
You have to change the filters.
Just throw it away and get another one.
They're like,
I don't know,
40 bucks.
I was like,
good,
another good,
another filter every 10 years.
That's it.
I think their warranty is like,
I don't know what to throw out a number,
but it's like a million gallons of just
something ridiculous.
That little thing can go through a
million gallons of water.
What does that filter smell like after
the ads that you're supposed to back
flush it.
Like my back flows when you back flushed
mind.
Alright,
you got the one way,
the dirty water goes through this way
and you just push through the crap right
out the other way and yeah,
when you do that on mine,
like it was just black water coming out.
Oh,
it's interesting to think like all that
black water.
It's just filtered out of what looks
like clean water,
clean water in the.
Well that is interesting.
Well it's also like you ever,
like,
especially
in Los Angeles is a great example of
this.
Have you ever gone to the hills and look
down on the basin of the La area and you
see that Brown air?
Yeah.
That's fucking disgusting.
But when you're there,
you don't see it.
It looks normal.
Walking around Hollywood,
you're like,
oh look air.
I can see right through it.
Your lungs are doing the same thing that
filters dylan like
brake dust.
That's the other thing.
The brake dust apparently is a real
issue with New York City and places
where you have real congestion in tight
areas.
You're breathing in a lot of dust from
the breaks of the cars.
Had no idea.
Yeah,
I didn't either.
I saw some of that smoke coming into La
and a connected it in Mexico City when I
was coming here in Mexico City was the
same way.
Mexico City was just like worst Mexico
cities like la is going to be in
probably 20 or 30 years.
What's it?
What's going on with the politics over
here?
I figured Joe would be clean air and
organic and not much we could do.
When you get the volume of people that
are here,
the amount of humans in La apparently
though the base in like especially like
the valley has always been like that.
It's always been kinda like a dust bowl,
just by the way it's shaped even back
before there were cars,
people always complained about the brown
air just from literally from dust and
dirt and wind and the dry air and the
lack of moisture.
So the the dirt kicks up easy with the
wind,
but then you add that with pollution as
well growth.
But we have $20,
million plus people in this tiny little
area.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean literally we have as many people
as the entire country of Australia in
the La area.
That's crazy.
Fucking really crazy.
There's just too many.
And now now that trump has lightened
that EPA protection standards and
they're,
they're changing the standards of
automobiles.
What automobiles need to achieve.
So supposedly to help business,
but fuck man.
What cost?
Yeah.
I think that seems like a short term
solution to a longterm problems.
Terrible idea.
I mean there's a reason why people,
why they set those standards and they're
trying to achieve cleaner and cleaner
standard.
So like if you go back,
apparently the 19 seventies in Los
Angeles,
the traffic was,
it was pollution was way worse because
when you're around those cars you ever
been around like old old cars like you
know,
1970 car.
Not particularly.
Now when you're around them,
apparently just an old car like that,
just sitting around a Po produces
pollution,
not even driving because the gas tank is
not airtight and fucking fumes leak out
into the environment,
just the oil.
Those things are always leaking oil and
shit.
When they drive,
they just traps.
That is disgusting.
There's just fire.
I mean they're basically just burning
gasoline is coming out the back and so
why are they different?
None of that regulations.
That's Manhattan from 1966.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Well that's those old cars,
man.
Old Cars were fucking terrible and
regulations fixed a lot of that stuff.
And the upper right hand corner is as
Los Angeles,
I got that fucking smog in La and it's
going to get worse now.
Mean he was getting better,
but it's going to get worse.
I mean,
if he really does succeed in lowering
the standards,
the emission standards.
So you're China.
China is awful.
It's just about to say visioning of you
who've been to China.
I've watched a documentary literally.
I literally like when I was in.
This was years ago,
but when I was in China I was just like
sick,
literally sick.
Like I was talking with a gravel voice.
It's just like people live there,
you know,
like every day.
Yeah,
no things.
Well that is got to be one thing that's
positive about doing the Appalachian
trail is that you're constantly in
nature and you're constantly around all
those trees and the walking through the
mountains and the healthy stuff.
Yeah.
You're drinking like A.
I'm not going to say that'll stream
waters clean,
but I mean,
yeah,
you're drinking
river water,
you're surrounded by trees all the time.
You're not near city lights,
like air pollution.
It's pretty.
And you're exercising every day,
all day,
you know,
it's pretty healthy way of life
in a way.
And it lets you start talking about
stress fractures.
So when you quit your job,
you,
you didn't just do the Appalachian trail
like you,
you kind of became a world traveler,
right?
Yeah.
And I still kind of am honestly.
Um,
yeah.
Like I'm in Guatemala right now.
And um,
what are you doing in Guatemala?
A working online,
you know,
I do a lot of green belly online.
So you live in Guatemala,
kind of a loose term,
you know,
living,
there's like,
have you ever heard the term digital
nomad?
Is that what you are?
I don't know if I identify myself as
that,
but that kind of movement of,
of working online and working remotely
so I can truly operate most of the
business on online.
Um,
so from that point of view,
it's like nowhere is off limits,
you know,
it's as long as there's decent Internet
connection.
So,
I mean my girlfriend are in Guatemala
for three months right now and then
we'll be in Europe and then Asia.
I can keep an apartment anywhere.
Anything AIRBNB.
Wow.
No possessions.
Truly.
Wow.
You're a renegade.
He out there fucking stomach.
Your nose.
It's society.
It's,
it's growing movement,
man.
Like there are a lot of people like
you'll go to these cities like ching
miles,
where it changed my Thailand was where I
was pretty much all of last year.
Our thousands of,
of like young international people like
running businesses off their laptop,
you know,
and I mean there are hubs all over the
world,
like,
like cheering Mai where they'll have
these like coworking cafes.
It's booming right now.
Like people are all over the world,
like you know,
twenties,
30 year olds just starting off a
business just makes a thousand dollars a
month income,
you know,
and then they'll slowly grow into $2,000
a month and you know,
next thing he knows they're replacing
their old salary at their old gig.
Yeah,
I know people who've done that in
Hawaii.
I've heard of people doing that in
Hawaii where they moved to Hawaii and
try to operate out of there.
And you know,
you're essentially still in the United
States,
but you're living in a beach life.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
if you can do it,
it's probably better than being trapped
somewhere.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Yeah.
And it's like,
no car,
no car payments,
no mortgage.
Like I dunno,
I mean,
I,
I like it,
I do,
you know,
I don't know about in a few years about
having kids if that's the way to go.
Yeah.
Um,
because I think like some,
some sense of stability in an
environment would be good.
But for now it's fantastic.
It's definitely good for the kids.
Whether it be you're an adult,
you know,
it's a different animal,
you know?
I mean,
I think also you get the,
a lot of the people that do that kind of
stuff,
he get really attached to this idea of
being free.
You could just pull up stakes,
throw your shit in a backpack and you're
gone.
Like,
how many bags do you have?
One.
I literally fit everything into one bag.
I have two pairs of shoes.
Wow.
It was like this,
this extreme minimalist living,
you know.
But I know a guy who does that and he's
in his sixties.
Steve,
my friend Steve Maxwell,
personal trainer,
was he living name is Trina who live in
California,
lives everywhere.
He doesn't have a place.
He's lived in hotels.
Yeah.
He hasn't had a place since I met him.
When I met him,
he had a,
uh,
a van that he lived out of,
like a big camper van and he slept in
that thing.
Then he sold that fucking thing.
He's like,
I don't need this,
and he's just has a bag.
He has a bag that's about that big and
he gets everything down to that bag.
He travels all over the world.
Less is more.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he's a guy that's done the opposite.
He had a gym and he had a house and the
family and the whole deal and his kids
grew up.
He got divorced.
He's like,
fuck this life.
And just became this kind of nomad type
person.
You know?
It's a fascinating idea that mean people
are so attached to the idea of
permanence when it's not real.
I mean,
no matter what happens,
you will die.
And all this stuff that you've nestled a
cohort.
Yeah.
Feathered your nest with.
It's not real.
It's like you're not going to keep it
white.
Amala.
Huh?
Come on down man.
How'd you choose that?
Costs like five bucks a year.
That's a,
that's a plus.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's close to home.
Um,
it doesn't have the best of health right
now.
So I do like the idea of being somewhat
a somewhat close to Georgia stuff needed
to come home.
How far is the flight from Guatemala and
the Georgia [inaudible]?
Four and a half hours.
So you can get.
They're almost the same as like living
on the east coast and flying to the
west.
Yeah.
And the same time zone.
It's,
it's cheap and it's like all of these
volcanoes around you hike all day long
and it's like the coolest thing about
that.
I'm an antiwar right now in tig was like
a,
I've,
there are several South American cities
like this or Central American cities and
they have the close to the equator.
So you have hot temperature all year
long,
kind of like a Megas,
California.
You're spoiled with it,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
Antigua specifically is that several
thousand feet of elevation.
So you have that consistent,
whether you're long,
however you are.
It's not 100 degrees every day.
So it's like,
um,
it's,
it's very similar to here.
It's like 75 degrees every day.
It's like 60 at night.
He speaks Spanish
when Poquito really I would think you
would learn these.
Speaks Spanish now.
But I know fornia
Spanish.
My Spanish is horrible.
I believe in dead like two months,
you know,
like I'm not,
I haven't,
I haven't picked it up.
Then I just got back from Cabo and I
felt bad that I didn't speak Spanish.
I was down there.
I tried,
you know,
I did the whole garage down there just a
week but a weekend.
Yeah.
But I would like,
I would think like if you stayed there
for any length of time,
like I have a friend who has a house
there,
it keeps house there and they go there
every month.
Motherfucker can't speak Spanish.
That's crazy.
Like you should learn their language.
No,
it's kind of like a guilty,
like an American privilege.
I got,
I'm not going to wait.
I was in Thailand for a year last year.
I don't know,
10 words in Thai.
Wow.
That's a shame on me.
But it's like,
it's a commitment to learn something
that fundamentally different,
you know?
Yeah.
Thai especially,
it's like no offense to learn a whole
new alphabet.
Totally.
You can't even read it.
Right.
It's like you gotta start way back to
kindergarten until,
you know,
at least Spanish.
You can kind of read letters.
Yeah.
So yeah,
ties like that crazy language.
You look at it.
It's like,
it's almost like,
like music,
like musical notes or something.
Yeah.
And it's like,
other than being in Thailand,
there's no advantage of knowing Thai.
No.
I don't mean to bash on Thailand,
but it's like a Spanish as much more
than incentives.
Like,
okay.
A lot of people speak Spanish.
That would be a great thing to know.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Spanish is probably next to English.
Maybe the most popular.
What is language?
Say Mandarin.
Maybe that's like a billion people,
but I don't know.
The numbers in Spanish was huge.
That seems like a grind.
Learning Mandarin.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Then you have to learn symbols.
I,
they're not even.
It's not even letters.
Yeah.
Fuck right there.
Grammar structure,
everything.
Yeah.
How do they text?
How to Chinese people text.
Oh my God.
How do they text?
How is it possible?
A
really.
That's a really good point.
Why should,
why should know this?
I should've already asked this question.
How do they have I asked this question?
Well,
I know in Thai you can switch your
keyboard and Thailand.
They switched their keyboard to.
I don't know.
I don't,
but they don't have the same numbers of
queues so I don't even.
Yeah.
But with Chinese characters and how the
fuck
would you send a text like,
you know,
like if you sent a late night booty call
was just like emojis,
you know,
Smiley face here now.
Yeah.
Smiley face.
Hard Dick,
exclamation point.
Thumbs up.
What is this?
Oh my God.
There they go.
They have,
they have a text,
but how many characters?
They just simplify.
Okay.
What is it?
Keyboard look like?
What does the Chinese character keyboard
on a cell phone look like?
Hm.
Yeah.
But that's a keyboard on a laptop.
What about cell phone?
Limited amount of keys.
How weird.
Oh Wow.
They have options.
Uh Oh wow.
Was Korean.
Huh?
So to piece them together.
And make,
I'm asking way too many questions.
We're not going to get the answers to
these either
at of all the places that you have
visited.
Um,
why did you choose Guatemala?
Uh,
close the United States.
I'm hiking.
Oh,
like in a place called Lake,
a teat lawn
man.
Go to lake.
A state law in that place is gorgeous.
It's like this massive thousand depot
thousand foot deep lake surrounded by
volcanoes.
Just like tiny little villages around
there.
They were just a little bit of googling
and it was kind of like,
hey,
why not let's go to Guatemala.
So did you go
as a visit and then decide to stay?
Or did you just go say let's see if we
can live here for a few months?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Uh,
I liked the idea of like going three
months at a time.
It's enough to kind of like find a gym,
find your restaurant's settle into
apartment,
like doing every few weeks.
It's just way too many logistics,
you know?
Um,
so I think we,
yeah,
we committed,
it was like three months down there.
I think we're going to commit to eastern
Europe for three months and then,
uh,
yeah,
coming back to Asia for three months
after the
whole expat lifestyle,
it takes a very different kind of
person,
you know,
to just say,
let's try living in another country.
Like when you say fit,
find a gym,
like what kind of gyms they have in the
little village in Guatemala.
They did literally
you mentioned that they had um,
paint buckets with cement and I'm for
real with pvcs and like I wouldn't work
out there.
That was like a teat line,
but Antigua's it really did.
It's like super ghetto stuff.
So they had paint buckets filled with
cement that are attached to sticks.
Yeah.
Literally that's how you worked out.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
but in tig was different.
That's like a more,
it's a bigger town city,
like they have a proper gym.
We go to yoga classes all the whole,
the whole nine yards.
Oh.
So it's almost like America.
It's totally.
So when you're using these paint buckets
with me,
didn't use him.
That was only at Laika teat line.
So I'm an Antiguan Elica teat.
I was only there for a month and lake
teat Atlanta is like a,
maybe like seven small villages
scattered around the lake and um,
they're actually indigenous.
It's like they're directly Mayan.
Oh Wow.
Those people.
Guatemala interesting is of all the
South American Central American
countries as the highest percentage of
indigenous people.
So it's like 30 percent indigenous so
they don't even speak Spanish.
Whoa.
It's crazy.
And they like,
what do they speak?
It's catch a cold kitchen.
So is it a Mayan dialect?
I believe so.
They're totally different people and
they dress traditional everything
thing.
It's intense.
Well they have a very strong will.
At least mine's did.
They had a very strange language where
you,
it's,
it's like,
there you go.
The letters or the images represent
sounds.
And so the sounds like,
like you,
like you would have like an eye.
Like this is how a Terence Mckenna
described it.
You'd have like an eyeball a saw an aunt
like a bug and then arose.
And that would be the way you say,
I saw aunt rose.
How do you know this was just from
Terence Mckenna?
Him talking about it because he's,
he,
he was,
uh,
he was a crazy psychedelic.
Did venture character,
do you know Mckenna is?
Maybe I should,
yeah.
He's a fascinating speaker,
like a who was a psychedelic lecture.
He was a botanist and just did way too
many drugs and,
or the right amount depending on who you
ask.
And uh,
he got really deep into the mind culture
and he was one of those guys that was
thinking that December 20,
first 2012 is going to be some crazy
event,
was not necessarily more of a shifting
of consciousness because it was a,
the end of the long count of the Mayan
calendar.
Yeah.
So,
well the Mayan calendar is a really
tricky thing,
man.
Like the sort of various different
decipher rings of it and the people that
are attached to all these different
meanings to it that don't necessarily
jive with the original meetings.
It was very hard to tell what the Mayans
men,
because they're not around anymore,
you know.
So it's not like you're,
you're studying ancient Russia where
people are rushing scholars and they
can.
There's a direct lineage between them
and the people.
Now you know,
when you said culture,
the language has gone and how we're
gonna fix.
Yeah,
they was.
There's like some,
some translations it took forever to
figure out and there's things that are
similar in some ways to a Rosetta stone
where they're trying to match up what it
used to be,
what it is,
what we try to figure out how you would
say these words in the context of the
culture that existed 2000 years ago as
opposed to today.
Like how would you,
Eva,
you're talking about the way they viewed
things,
the way they communicated was incredibly
different.
That's has an interesting.
Yeah,
it's fascinating stuff.
There was a,
there was a great documentary decoding
the Maya.
That was A.
I think it was a nat geo.
It sounds like that guy.
Fuck I'm going to send you that.
Yeah,
I think it was.
And it just detailed how difficult it
was for these people to try to figure
out who these symbols and say,
all right,
what do these mean?
What the fuck do they mean?
And apparently there was a really recent
breakthrough where they found a bunch
of,
I don't think they called them
hieroglyphs,
I don't know what they actually call
them,
uh,
but they,
they found a bunch of previously
undiscovered Mayan language that sort of
filled in some pieces that they hadn't,
hadn't filled in before.
Then you look at some of the amazing
murals that looked like a guy seated in
a spaceship with fire below his seat and
you try to figure out what the fuck this
man.
Like a lot of those ancient alien alien
theorists,
right?
Oh,
you ever seen that one?
There's one is a really crazy as it
looks like a guy who's leaning back in
like a,
like a spaceship.
It looks like he's leaning back in the
cockpit chair and he's looking through
something that looks like a telescope
and he's moving some,
uh,
some levers with his hands and it looks
like there's fire beneath him.
It really bizarre,
fascinating stuff.
So that was drawn a long time ago.
Yeah,
there it is right there.
That's the.
I guess there's a go full screen with
that one right there that you got right
there.
Yeah.
See,
so below him as fire.
He sitted he's moving some stuff with
his feet.
He's moving some levers and you see how
he's looking through that thing and it
looks like it's got like a gas mask on
like an oxygen mask and all those people
that like the von Danek and guys like
they believed that what this showed was
a man sitting in a cockpit using the
levers and machines to operate some sort
of a spaceship.
So wherever that spaceship from most
likely it didn't exist.
Most likely these guy was for highest
fuck on the mushrooms and they're
probably imagining the future.
I mean if I had to guess,
I would say that these ideas were
probably very psychedelically based
because they were really into
psychedelic drugs.
They had found a lot of different drugs
and a lot of different vines that
contained lysergic acid and it's one of
the.
I had a did a trip to Chichen Itza,
which is really cool,
bunch of years back and I had a
professor that was the guide.
It was really cool because you could
hire people for a guy.
Then we got this guy who was a professor
in mine history and he when he knew that
I was really into it and I asked all
these questions,
he was super psyched,
so he went way deep into it and we had
it for like six hours.
He took us on this grand tour,
but one of the things he showed us this
area of one of the pyramids were they
used to do these psychedelic rituals and
he was talking about these.
They used to take these,
these vines that had some sort of
lysergic acid in it and they would have
these psychedelic rituals and one of
the,
one of the things they used to do when
they were studying the stars and you
know,
looking at it,
obviously no,
no light pollution back then.
Right?
So these guys are tripping their balls
out on acid staring at this beautiful
star scape.
And what's the DNA of the violence still
around home and I remember because it
was so long ago that I went,
I went and like
early two thousands,
2002 or something like that.
I think we went,
but it was amazing.
They just think that you're standing on
the ground where these people existed
and they had this bizarre culture that
we don't understand that was aligned to
the cosmos.
Like the other structures were based on
constellations,
like the,
the maps of these structures mirrored
constellations and they were really into
a astronomy and some sort of a weird
way.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
right over your head.
Like how the fuck did they,
they,
they apparently there's evidence that
they knew about the procession of the
equinoxes which is a 20 something
thousand year cycle of wobble of the
earth.
Yeah.
Because they see that the earth isn't
just spin,
you know,
it doesn't just spin perfectly.
It spins with like a little bit of a
wobble.
So the night sky changes and it goes
into this 26,
I think it's 26,000 year cycle.
And they apparently knew about that.
What,
how,
how?
No,
yeah,
I guess if you have a lot of time back
then and there's no iphone constantly
distract you with checking your twitter
picture on Instagram,
you know,
you're instead you just looking at
constellations.
I just don't know how they would,
how they would market,
how they,
how will they would.
I mean,
I guess that they would see that there's
some sort of subtle changing of the
night sky in terms of like how it would
move a little bit all the time.
Not just move.
Obviously the night sky moves with the
seasons,
you're looking at a different image as
the sun moves and this planet spins,
but it's just the,
the idea that these people had figured
out all these different things.
Like in terms of like mapping
constellations so long ago.
Wild.
Yeah.
Amazing.
I just,
it's,
it's fucked up that we don't know what
they were saying.
You know,
like we've never heard their language.
Like it's one of the things about one of
these,
uh,
other documentaries that I watched was
that they were trying to mimic what the
sound of these Mayan languages could
have been like.
And they really,
it was kind of guesswork,
but they didn't know,
they can see if there's something that
you find or something where they,
um,
hear what the Mayan language could have
sounded like.
There was some sort of a really bizarre
like clicks or something I them,
which is weird language,
but they don't even know if that's right
because there's no one around total
guests.
They just died.
They just went away,
you know,
it's,
it's weird.
And then the language got absorbed and
obviously these people that you were
talking about probably have some sort of
a dialect and.
Yeah.
And I have no idea what the correlation
was between the current descendants in
what you're talking about.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
what's really bizarre is it's not that
long ago in terms of human history
because if you look back and like human
history in Europe,
like there's places in Europe you can
visit that are 2000 years old.
I mean,
isn't there a fucking bar somewhere in
Europe that's like almost 900 years old
or something,
something crazy like that.
So these,
I believe that the Mayan civilization
they think was not,
not more than 2000 years ago.
Here it is.
Sean's bars,
a pub in athlone.
Ireland is the oldest pub in Ireland.
Goes back to 900.
Eight d older than 100 years old.
Jesus Christ.
Two thousand 900 years old essentially.
Oh,
980.
Okay.
But think about that.
That's a thousand.
Well,
it says oldest pub in Europe.
So what's the oldest?
The oldest pub in the world?
That's a good question.
But just think of that 900.
Add that.
So that's,
that's three or 400 years before gingiss
con you old trip to Jerusalem.
One,
1000.
One hundred.
$8.
80 nine 8,980.
So that seems like the oldest.
Yeah it does.
And the 900 a day.
Wow.
More than 1100 years ago.
Fucking a man.
Just crazy that much older than America.
Yeah.
So book one was the Mayan civilization
when,
when was the,
was the decline of the Mayan
civilization.
See if you find that
it is pretty amazing when you stop and
think about it.
Think about just the bizarre history of
the human race and that there are these
civilizations that have these.
They lived and he sort of isolated
environments where they developed in
many ways parallel sort of building
techniques but different than other
parts of the world that were also based
on constellations.
Like very similar to a lot of the
hypothesis about Egyptian culture is
that they had done that collapse.
It goes,
wow,
980.
That's insane.
So right,
right on the light.
When that bar was built,
maybe the bar fucking caused it.
They all went to Ireland.
Got Hammered.
That wow,
that's a coincidence that entered a 80
right there.
Nine hundred 80 up and down,
but what a bizarre and complex
civilization the Mayans were.
See if you could find out this is what
the Mayan language sounded like.
I found a,
but it's psycho.
A woman living currently.
It's like,
this is what it could have sounded like.
I don't know if that's the best
one.
Let's hear what she says.
Let me see what it may be me.
Maybe there's some of it left.
You know,
you could take on anything.
I don't know if that's the same.
Oh,
you could.
Yeah.
They'll say you could open it.
That's where the city near Guatemala.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Maybe
doesn't sound like anything that I've
ever heard before.
Spanish words drugged.
It says what you could.
Maya sounds really sounds like.
What is it?
What's the description?
So this guy had his housekeeper describe
what this older woman was saying.
Oh,
go back to look at it.
It says attention Mel Gibson.
Yes.
She saw that movie apocalypto and had a
hard time understanding the mind that
they were speaking in that movie.
If you listen closely,
you can hear a few Spanish words mixed
in where there are no mind words,
Huh?
Wow.
Interesting.
Apocalypto.
That's really interesting.
Maybe he claimed that they were speaking
at or something like that or what?
That movie,
I don't want to get done in apocalypto
mean you're talking about a dead
language.
How could you get a guest to.
What did he do with apocalypto?
Did he use Spanish?
Did he mix it in with stuff?
I would imagine that we'd hire some sort
of language experts,
but
what else?
He might might've been busy getting
drunk and yelling at choose
curse curse.
Now his ex wife
thing that I pulled up off of mental
floss is that,
uh,
if like 15 fun facts about the movie,
it says that he was a stickler for
authentic language and all of the
dialogue is you could take Maya
language.
So.
Oh,
well huh.
That's where the discrepancy is in that
maybe he said he used it all and she's
saying I speak it not unrecognized.
What she's not saying that she spoke it.
If you read what she said she was saying
that she had given this woman a massage
and the woman was speaking to her and
that she recognized a few words in
Spanish,
but she didn't.
Yeah,
I don't think there's a bridge between
that lag.
I don't think there's anybody who knows
that language and also speaks English
that can crazy man.
That whole part of the world is so then
you go back to like the in the old macs,
they don't even know who those people
were.
Those strange,
almost African looking phases.
They,
those gigantic stone structures that
they found that there could be thousands
of years old.
Are you talking about off of the coast
of Ecuador?
Yeah.
The old Mac are there almost like a
hypothetical situation or,
or a,
uh,
they don't.
They don't necessarily know where these
people came from.
They don't know who they were and some
people have said they look a lot like,
like really strong featured,
um,
South American folks.
And some people have actually compared
the way the old mex were depicted in
these structures,
these statues and things that they look
more like Africans,
you know,
this has been like speculation that
these are people that might have come
from Africa on boats.
That's been widely criticized too.
But the point is they don't really know
much about the old Mex.
You ever seen images from the seat pull
up?
I'm old MAC statues o l m e C,
I believe it's the way they spell it.
But again,
that's just phonetic.
They don't,
I don't even know what language these
people spoke and these are.
So these are some statues and things
that they found in South America.
Look at these.
Oh yeah.
Seen that.
He's so.
They have different legends of the
Hidden Temple.
Did you ever see that show?
It was a joke.
I said that.
I thought that was going to pull up the
Nickelodeon TV show.
Oh No,
no.
I'm thinking of no.
The omex like,
look at that one.
The third one over from the top.
Look at that.
I mean that looks very African,
doesn't it?
We really thick lips.
Wide noses,
large nostrils.
Really interesting.
Mean these people,
they don't exactly know what their
culture was.
They don't exactly know who they were.
It's hard to carbon date as well because
you're dealing with stone so until they
find,
you know,
things that are around there that they
can back date.
I think that the estimate is 6,000
years.
I might've made that up though.
See?
See if you could find out.
Like what?
How long ago were the old Mex?
The.
You could see it back where you just
were.
What does it say?
They're going to be saved?
Jesus.
Everything is done at RBC.
I was 80 they before.
Oh yeah.
Why am I screwing that up?
Dealing with this,
I'm in pain right now dealing with this.
How's it doing better?
But fuck man,
I was in Mexico this week and I got
severely sunburn on my back.
Put sunscreen everywhere.
But my back,
I've had young Jamie in a very non
gateway lather on this.
Uh,
Aloe Vera Anti.
But I'm very distracted.
It's just like a,
like almost like I have 100 things all
over my back.
Not No Bueno.
So that's 900 BC.
They think the old mex lived.
What's that estimate based on?
Because I saw something that was like,
it thought it was there were way older
than that.
Wonderful.
I know the date from at least before 900
BC.
That's.
See,
I think there's like a conventional way
of thinking and then there's an
alternative theory and the alternative
it was that they were way,
way,
way older than that,
but I don't think they know.
They don't know who the Omex were,
but cool shit,
you know,
they left behind these giant heads and
like,
oh why'd you even do that?
No one knows.
Have you seen that thing?
I was watching this one documentary or
one television show where either on the
Amazon and uh,
they've,
they've recently because of satellite
images found in city while they found
what they think are the thing is
evidence of hidden cities have evidence
of ancient cultures now in the Amazon.
Um,
and I think it was Brazil,
I don't think it was Honduras,
but they found,
um,
like what would appears to be irrigation
structures and things that are carved
into the ground and things that look
like grids where they might've had
cities and streets.
That was the lost city of gold member
there were said last Silverado.
Yeah,
yeah.
The people are looking for.
And that one,
a European explored,
went looking for and wound up dying and
they believe it got eaten by cannibals
because they're making a movie about
that.
Right.
We talked about this recently,
some movie about the lost city of gold
that's on its way.
I had a,
I think it was Disney did one event
animation one like 20 years ago.
That was a bug.
Well,
there's always been rumors that there
was these lost cities in the Amazon,
but now thanks to satellite imagery,
they're starting to see things they
never saw before and starting to find
patterns and structures and it's cool
shit man.
His cool.
Well it's what's really crazy is like if
we didn't have this stuff,
like how long would it be before there
was no evidence,
would it be another thousand years?
So like how if you go back to when was,
when were these structures with they
2000 years old,
were they a thousand years old?
So if we,
if we think about it like who knows what
was there in the Amazon,
who knows what was their 5,000 years
ago,
10,000 years ago.
I mean it could have been completely
lost civilizations that we just,
we'll never know.
We'll never have any awareness of
you freaking out,
man.
Look at you.
I'm never to know.
Do you have any plans other than you
said you were going to visit Eastern
Europe.
He lived in Guatemala.
Now you're going to live there for
awhile and do you have any other like
wild plans and places to go and
uh,
talking about Thailand again at the,
at the end of the year?
Um,
other than that,
no,
that's,
that's about as far ahead as I thought.
I mean honestly,
like I,
I came to my buddy was in Ohio,
I don't know if you.
Oh,
hi.
It's a town.
Yeah.
Um,
and we went into surfing yesterday,
up there and I was just like,
I liked it and we were surfing around
lunchtime and then we went for a hike in
the afternoon.
It's just gorgeous.
I mean it's like the fact that you can
go surfing in the day and then for a,
I'm in a gorgeous.
You could look like these trails just
snake on forever.
I was like,
California
was like,
okay,
maybe California is on the radar.
California is pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
Northern California is really intense,
like the rain forest area where the
redwoods are.
Have you been up there
yet?
Yeah,
I've been up there.
Those big,
this big red was this gorgeous Pacific
northwest.
Looks beautiful too.
I've never been up there.
Yeah,
it is.
It's really interesting and super dense.
Forest up there,
like really dense because it's
constantly raining.
And what's really interesting about the
forest is the other so many pine trees
and there's so many leaves fall at the
forest floor is really soft.
Yeah.
He like,
yeah,
like you're stepping on this cushion
everywhere you walk.
It looks beautiful though.
It is a lot of ferns and [inaudible].
Yeah,
it's very,
very alive.
What do you do if you have hunted up
there before?
Uh,
I also went up there looking for
bigfoot.
That TV show that I did.
You did?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we went,
we went big foot hunting up there for a
week.
Did you find them?
We found a lot of white guys out camp
and looking for bigfoot.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a joke that I said,
here's what you don't find when you go
looking for bigfoot.
Black people are more likely to find big
foot.
Then you are black people looking for
big bunch of white guys camping.
He's accurate.
And it was interesting because one of
the guys that we've talked to is like,
hey look,
even when we don't find anything least
we're out here camping.
I was like,
Eh,
that's the worst case scenario is pretty
good.
But there's a lot of people out there
that claim they seen things but I just
think they're seeing bears because there
are bears up there,
there's a lot of black bears up there
and you see them in the distance and
bears do walk on two legs all the time.
And I think if you see one in the
distance and you see that image and you
convince yourself that that's bear or
that's a big foot rather not a bear.
And after awhile your memory starts to
memories are so bad.
Like the human memory.
So in inherently shitty.
I mean a few people have like very clear
distinct memories from the past.
But I think even though you're sort of
repeating them to yourself and
ingraining them in your head until you
believe it until you believe him.
But I think like what,
what our memories are good for is like
recent events or things that are
catastrophic,
like don't go near the snake,
the snake will kill you.
You know that spiders got venom.
Oh,
I remember the spider,
you know,
but like as far as like seeing things
and being around especially unusual
events that are very unique,
like seeing a seven foot tall monkey in
the woods or believing you saw that
thing.
Yeah,
no doubt.
I think he's seen as a,
the studies of the hub,
like a criminal break into a room and
then they'll ask all the other witnesses
how tall was he?
Like was he black?
Was He white?
Like all these specific characteristics
and like they're all over the place.
Yeah.
Human memory is unbelievably bad and we
count on it so much and people are
always like telling you stories about
their childhood.
I remember when this hub and he was
like,
do you really?
How much do you really remember?
It's like,
you might really.
And how delusional are you?
That's the other part of the problem.
Like how,
how much do you remember of things like
what is,
how much do you distort reality to her
to fit within your narrative that you
enjoy?
Make a good story,
right?
Yes.
Enjoy.
Yeah.
You must run into a lot of those people
when you're out there on the,
on the hat,
as it were,
was this sasquatch chased dear onto
highway woman tells deputy wow.
She sounds pretty fucking legit.
She's 1550 year old tents.
It was tented tensed.
It's the city.
I guess 10 said woman.
Fifty years old.
She's probably on pills.
Whacked out of her mind.
Maybe drunk.
No.
No,
so,
so legit dude.
But it's an Idaho again.
Idaho high bear population.
I know.
I was fucking grizzly bears.
It's probably out there,
whacked out on fucking pills.
She sees a bear.
She can't wait to call the police.
Finally,
my life has meaning.
Had 50 years old.
I'm the first one in my town.
It's a big.
She goes and tells people.
Did you run into any wildlife?
It was weird when you're out there.
I don't know if bears are considered
weird,
but yeah,
embarrassed.
There was,
um,
it was 2013.
They were like,
you know,
Congress seems to shut down about once
every decade for budget disagreements.
Yeah.
In 2013 they shut down.
And um,
uh,
yeah,
so they shut down the whole national
park system.
So you eat,
he goes through a lot of national parks.
So when they should have the national
park system,
nobody's allowed to go into the park,
meaning.
So it's like,
what the hell are we supposed to do?
Even hiking for four months and now
you're just going to say you can't go
through these sections.
So it ended up everybody just kind of
kept on hiking,
but the ranges would kick you out.
So she had to do is you'd hike at night.
Oh God,
I'm.
So you're hiking at night.
But the best thing about hiking unite as
a wildlife,
you know,
because it's like you start.
And so like specifically Shenandoah
national park,
um,
it gets a ton of visitors.
And so when they shut down the national
park,
the only people in there were us.
It was like three hikers for this 100
mile section of park.
So it was like,
and the Shenandoah national park,
I believe is one of the highest
concentrated black bird populations in
the country.
Oh Jesus.
So you have like no disturbance and you
have all these barriers.
So,
um,
you know,
we'd be hiking the night I was actually
alone,
um,
at this point.
But um,
yeah,
I was hiking through the night one night
and yeah,
like the sun was rising and you know,
like a bear's will go to sleep at night
and the trees and when you pass by them
you triberr and they'll come out of the
tree and the claw their way down the
tree and you know,
it's a slow their fall.
But it was like,
I think I saw 15 beers that morning.
I was just cool though.
It was cool.
It was just like,
now when you're hiking a using
headlamps,
are you just going by the moonlight or
both?
I mean,
yeah,
moonlight if you can.
Uh,
it's surprising like your,
you know,
your eyes adjust and the night I have a
lot of times,
but if you're under like heavy trees,
you know,
that's not going to work.
But yeah,
hadn't headlamps.
Definitely.
And how long was Congress?
How long did they shut down?
And national parks.
I remember who went too long.
There was a couple weeks something.
I mean some hikers we knew like
literally holed up in a hotel for a
couple of weeks until they settled it
committed.
It's just like,
what is a range of really gonna arrest
you and throw you in jail for like
hiking a through hiker,
like hiking through the park.
It's weird that they tell you you can't
go anymore.
I mean,
isn't this like public lands?
I think we all kind of rolled her eyes
are most of us rolled our eyes at it
like.
All right dude,
come on.
I'm just,
I'm just walking through here,
you know.
So
this company that you have,
um,
green belly meals,
which I've enjoyed these things very
much.
You,
you came up with this because you needed
more nutrition while you were out there.
It's hard to find good stuff to eat.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
and prior to the ato is doing,
um,
I was the of the term cycle touring.
You've like backpacking on a bike,
you hop on a bicycle and you cycle,
you know,
5,100 miles a day and then you camp out
at night.
So did that New Zealand for three or
four months and it was the same thing.
It's just like burning a ton of
calories.
Men,
um,
and I needed everything to be light and
ready to eat,
um,
and then yet came over to the states and
right after that trip on the Appalachian
trail and the backpacking food consisted
of,
you know,
those dehydrated freeze dried meals that
you add hot water to,
um,
those things like I don't like stopping
and cooking at all,
you know,
like if I can keep going,
particularly at meals like lunch,
just keep going.
Um,
and like the meal options were bars,
other bars,
bars usually cap out at like 200
calories,
250 even meal replacements.
The,
the highest calorie meal replacement bar
on the market.
Um,
it was a 400 calorie,
uh,
I believe met Rx,
you know,
some of those workout,
a high protein bars.
Um,
and not to mention that like heavily
processed,
you know,
I was like,
I just didn't want to put up much of
that crap in me.
Um,
and I mean to add another thing was the
just balanced nutrition.
Some bars would have fiber,
some,
wouldn't someone have protein,
some wouldn't.
Someone have carbs and witnessed like,
dude,
I need nutrition.
Like I'm,
I'm really burning up to five to 6,000
calories a day,
you know.
Um,
so that kind of idea of,
of the need for a big nutrition ready to
eat fast,
um,
you know,
kind of eaten,
go kind of meal with something that had
been forming in my mind is I hiked a lot
of times we were drinking olive oil
practically and drinking honey and
drinking peanut butter.
It's just like anything you could get to
load in the calories.
So I'm,
you know,
I'm not a big dude so I was like I
couldn't afford to lose that much weight
and I was losing weight.
I'm so green belly kind of came up with
the idea when I was hiking.
Like,
let's make something that packs in some
calories,
you know,
pack.
How did you do that though?
How did you like these things are super
dense,
like for people that are listening,
I'm holding this bag and as two bars in
it and a dude I eat,
I've eaten these before.
I've eaten two bars and I'm good for
fucking a day,
just a normal day.
Like not hiking or anything crazy,
but it's really dense.
They're heavy,
like you hear that phone.
So it's a brick of food.
Like how did you figure out how to do
that?
Uh,
I knew nutritionally I had an idea of
where I wanted it to be or you know,
as a concept for like this kind of
ultimate backpacking meal.
Um,
and then I worked with a food scientist,
so I knew that I knew nothing about
nutrition.
I just kind of knew I wanted to scratch
my own itch,
you know,
I had an itch and I wanted a,
I wanted a better backpacking meal.
So I knew conceptually what I wanted it
to be.
And then after playing around my mom's
kitchen trying to get something,
I was like,
this is way over my head,
you know,
like trying to get the nutritional
nutritional profile where I want it to
be good at,
to taste good,
like ingredients that don't react with
each other and spoil and then trying to
get it to literally form together and
not fall apart.
It's like you start like having this
really complicated stuff as I try to
just find her,
you know,
um,
search around and see,
you know,
what kind of person who can help me.
I was looking right in nutritionists and
chefs and all that kind of stuff and
ended up coming with the term food
scientists and food scientists helped me
really formulate the meal.
And then,
um,
you know,
then it was just kind of a feedback game
from what he could do a from a
nutritional point of view from a shelf
life and flavor profile.
Then it was just making sure the darn
things tasted good,
you know?
Um,
so I went to like a hiking festival,
handed out hundreds of samples,
just got a bunch of feedback from hikers
and then um,
yeah,
kind of ran with it and um,
that's been doing well.
Well,
they're good man and I eat them all the
time.
So,
uh,
I,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm impressed.
I really delicious.
You know,
my favorite one is a chocolate one
though.
Was that which one?
Dark chocolate?
Yeah,
dot dot.dot banana.
Yeah.
We have been in chips and then,
but
good shit dude.
Real Scott.
I'm trying to stay on a ketogenic diet.
A funny joke.
I was like,
yeah man,
we got,
we got high carbs.
Yeah,
that's not going to work on a cheat
mail.
These are good.
Or if I'm desperado for food,
but also she,
you can think about a ketogenic diets as
you can every now and then fuck up as
long as you're not,
you know,
as long as you're pretty consistent with
a high fat content diet.
And then what I'll do is I'll take an
exogenous ketone can take a like,
drinks that you mix up that put you in a
ketogenic state even after you could
drink like a whole coca cola and then
drink one of these key to genic drinks
and it knocks you back in a state of
ketosis.
Well,
yeah,
it was pretty scientific shit.
This guy,
dom d'agostino invented it.
He's a scientist at the University of
Florida.
Interesting.
Yeah.
There's,
there's ways you can manipulate your
metabolism that way where it
specifically burns fat.
There's a lot of benefits.
One of the big benefits is your,
um,
your appetite.
Appetite suppressants amazing because if
I go on and I did,
I do switch over,
like if I cheat,
like if I go on vacation or something
like that and I just started eating
tacos or whatever.
When you,
uh,
your body goes into carbohydrate burning
state,
you way hungrier,
like you burned through that
carbohydrate pretty quickly.
It's quick burning fuel and then your
body doesn't have the carbs anymore.
So then you go into this real hungry
state.
Whereas if you're in a ketogenic state,
your body's burning fat,
you're eating fats,
and then when there's no more food,
your body starts burning it's own fat,
and so you don't get that crazy hunger
craving that you get when you're in a
car based Diet and there's,
you know,
there's arguments for both sides and um,
I'm going to bring in some people that,
uh,
are anti ketogenic diet as well,
so get
balanced perspective on it.
I listened to 'em,
I don't remember his name,
but it was a nutritionist.
He had written a book.
He was on your podcast a while ago.
[inaudible] Chris crusher.
Gary tobbs the case against sugar.
Please not a nutritionist.
This is pretty recently.
Robb wolf real recently.
I wanna say it was real recent wired to
eat robb wolf.
That sounds,
that sounds right,
rob.
But the level of nutrition that,
that guy knew,
I was fascinated.
That's rob.
Yeah,
that must be wrong,
man.
Whoa.
That was impressive.
He's the actual guy that invented the
concept of quote unquote bulletproof
coffee that got kind of stole it.
Robb Wolf's concept came first and he
wrote about it in 2005,
the idea of adding mct oil and butter to
give healthy fats with coffee.
Yeah.
Rob is a scientist and he's.
He's like way ahead of the curve.
June and oppressive like Kilz
conversation was just interesting.
Yeah,
there's a lot of those guys out there
now.
It's really a fascinating time when it
comes to nutrition and and also what he
was really good about him is he's
constantly experimenting.
He's very honest and very open about his
experiments and he's also really adamant
about the possibility,
not the,
not the hospital,
but the reality rather that people are
very different and everyone's
variability.
The variability is very wide.
So like what is healthy for you might
not necessarily be healthy for me.
And what,
what changes your blood sugar levels is
not going to change mine.
It's a very,
very different
interesting stuff.
So it's like when you remember when
those conversation I was thinking like,
is there something out there?
Just a simple blood test or something
where it's just like,
what do I need to know?
What's good for me?
What's the,
what's the simplest way to find out is
this good?
Is this bad?
What do I need?
Yeah,
really just have to experiment and then
on top of that there's a lot of other
variables like how much sleep are you
getting?
What's your cortisol levels?
Well,
how much stress are you under?
And those factors also have to be taken
into consideration when you formulate a
diet because you're.
It'll vary depending upon your stress
levels.
It's
complicated stuff.
Very,
very complicated.
But these delicious shit.
So I wish you well with this,
my friend.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
him,
you Fox
and the book how to hike the Appalachian
trail is available everywhere,
right?
Yeah,
and that was just a fun side project.
Truly just wrote that in about a,
about a month or just kind of sat down
and cranked out how to hike the tea.
So it's geared talk,
whole bunch of stuff,
you know,
a few trail tales in there.
Listen,
I was,
I really enjoyed talking to you man.
Now you've lived a fascinating life and
you continue to do so.
So good luck to you and thanks again.
Thanks Joe.
Good talk,
Christopher cage.
Ladies and gentlemen.
No relationship to Nicholas.
Say folks.
Bye.